all right and we are laughs welcome to
the i lords podcast and the lords a
gaming dotnet episode number 119 and
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
very excited about our special guests
and we've got switch joy contrast Fire
Emblem gave me with a year Wolfenstein
Youngblood Phil Spencer Fortune
interview and Noah dog studio crutch to
discuss so we go get right in so you
notice how extra he said that game of
the year I wanna introduce a Lord whose
content I came across to fellow Redfern
to the room Louis tell 40k now is this
law was the most passionate endo content
creators in the realm but it's
infectious humor heartfelt videos and
high-quality editorials truly stand out
in everything he does introducing the
creator and host of the Nintendo guru
youtube channel website and community
manager for a 2e games LLC formerly
known to the Romans the geek guru this
Lord has ascended to the guru of
Nintendo and always keeps it real with a
if grandpa Nintendo is acting up from
Jersey and making his debut into the
realm of the Lords mom made Lord Bobby
aka the Nintendo guru how you doing sir
I dude okay listen I know you guys watch
w evacuate and you know the rock right
the rock would even come out like I got
goose bumps right like dude I got goose
bumps right now for that introduction
yeah I'm getting rain don't walk out the
door thank you so much man guys man is
an honor
seriously reach out to me a few weeks
ago like hey we do something I'll say
yeah yeah we can do something then like
six months later he's like hey we're
ready for you now
seriously thank you for the invite man I
appreciate it much love a huge fan of
what you do man you a lord in your rooms
was only right we show you the proper
respect here at the round table
I think big fan man we got a we got the
Guru in the building I've had people's
you don't meet him in the same sitting
I'm waiting for you to write me up I'm
coming up play with amiibo all day you
will not get out no we have the full
cost of gaming those original Lords at
the realm he at the round table my calls
would call most my brother from another
mother
the difficult game Kagura and the heart
of the young wolf mommy
Lord addict how you doing sir doing
pretty good I want to point out that I
was thirty minutes early she going on
this rampage that it's just recently
attics been on time apology from your
side of the early table Thank You
breakfast and all early in the face
here's the question you say you were
here early
oh gee but you got no can we don't know
you check then right I'll punch my clock
how I do work
Oh attic are you alive this week or you
out of yeah a little run was concerned
man you feeling a little better yeah I
saw you guys were letting King like go
off last with no disappointed in you
guys see I would have been there right
with them but you know who's in lockstep
with that I must be this week but we
will be next week this week yeah you're
on the side of good a lot to do a
certain game you know and of course we
have our most technical gaming Lord the
solo game of lives for the single player
selfish experience and also the sastra
Thomas mr. or flower profile Illuminati
and Lord patreon of the iron bank mommy
Lord sovereign I do is it I'm alright
one of those days pulling yourself up
from under the table yeah it was a
struggle no idea this week was crazy man
like I expected to be off a good part of
the week and that didn't happen and then
you know occupational hazard I got a
little bit injured and I have a
scratched cornea so I'm hoping like I'm
looking like big boss right now knowing
that I would be not saying he was on the
switch the horn physical ailment I'm a
little bit a little bit just yesterday
and a little bit this morning some of
that wolfenstein are young blood we'll
talk about that a little bit and of
course big releases I'm feeling these
Friday releases man always lose a stuff
I love Friday releases big fan big fan
meant to be as know damn well this
doesn't happen often we celebrate like
the thirtieth game release it on Friday
what Nintendo's been good about the
Friday's that's their day even Sunday
like weirdly like Sunday's stupid but
whatever and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the excess
gamer who the lord of combat sports king
of the statues who demands nothing less
than that premium and experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
who beloved Lord K how you doing sir I'm
doing incredible this week alright guys
so update on I'm putting a collage video
together for the dearly departed Sir
Benjamin Johnson who left us in February
and I took Lord hot monkeys advice and I
got a little mature dog she's two years
old her name is of the Baroness oh
that's a fishing Monica meaning green
Johnson oh so she's a Frenchie of course
and she's two years old she's the same
age that our Benjamin would have been at
this Junction his life he was one month
earlier than how he was born in June and
she was born in July and I came across
her story I saw her story and I I don't
know I bonded through the pitches in
through reading the story so I decided
to go see her saw her spoke to the lady
about her because she was available for
sale and I decided to you know take a
chance and it's been working out pretty
much she's she's pretty much premium she
wants um-hmm this really special food
that I purchased her that we got yeah I
already got a starter I win
harness because she was sharing her
harness in an apartment with four to
five dogs a lot yeah sheshe needed their
attention in that love so you know now
she just how I would sleep on the couch
and you know what my feet are watching
TV and Benjamin would be right there
she just like jumped em right into
pocket yeah I know you've been a journey
for you it's been right all right - chat
- chat give a love shot to your hands
else and rest in peace opposite bedroom
but this is a new new beginning for you
and we're glad you did it man we're glad
you did it pictures to be up on all
Lords of gaming that night and lion Lord
podcasts on Instagram everything is
gonna go up I'm just you know trying to
get everything out though she'll be down
here now but they're walking her right
now okay no doubt any gaze you've been
playing surge it's been all busy with
destiny whoa yo so iron banner came out
right you know I'm a junkie right oh oh
oh oh wait whoa whoa I have to call the
fraud alert on alert outlet or Microsoft
or was the game pass ultimate right so
I'm thinking yo we all in I still get
the games of gold right so games ago
popped up and it was some in this is
what I do and what are those little dues
that the games come up I don't care if I
wanted a nut I'm in shock get it
download it and later whenever I choose
is mine is free well no one you know
it's not yours anymore games of gold
don't apply to you if you have game's
ultimate really soul right this is
listen let me download it you check your
credit card now your credit card now I'm
looking at my email
microsoft says thank you for your
purchase mm-hmm 1495
oh no
it was the game I just downloaded I said
boy oh no no we got to refund this this
was a mistake subscriptions yes and
games with gold is done but wait a
minute is it a song you might have
accidentally just clicked the button to
pay for it rather than gold is rolled
into right now
I did the same thing I normally do now I
am afraid if you did the same thing you
normally do we wouldn't have this
conversation in my email over to switch
our game store and purchase a better
game I have no idea right now
they have actually defecated all all
games ago yeah right oh game pass now
it's like this month is a Meet the
Robinsons or something yes yeah
something with your account your
subscription as far as like on the
ultimate maybe he didn't roll over right
absolutely sure the ultimate is better
make sure your ultimate is yet a naming
community strike what happens is
ultimately supposed to cancel out the
old game pass and then it's a transition
you have to manually do that did it
listen I got I got ultimate game pass
all the way up to 2026 something like
that some wow number um and I looked at
it cancelled the joint cuz I look it was
one two and then the third one was games
of gold it was like mad mmm okay yo EJ
shot the EJ buddy said he downloaded
meet the Robinson he gonna check his
account now
let's be fair though like the Microsoft
Store is so it's as trashman Oh
like it's so hard to find stuff
everything's all over the place no sorry
have a super chat did you do a dress
shout out to the ID is e81
widow five dollars superjet On January 6
1994 a famous me was i dizzy 81 I don't
know who you are but I think you're onto
something
music dizzy when you're solve nieces in
that box on the side have the same
enthusiasm handing your knees over the
same hand over your bread we have the
Lord the cooperative experience in
gaming ninja himself the shinobi Lord
Cognito spread never illness in the
realm of the ILP now tell me what you
want to hear but what you need to hear
shout out to my man mark small for
copping his Nintendo switch he's in the
building guys Marvel Ultimate Alliance
on shout the recoil for having the
patience in the world to try to set this
thing up over the ball play on automatic
come on don't you feel like every time
someone buys a switch this man want to
act like someone just are you asking
king you know king is all knee deep in
the xbox kool-aid so you
[Laughter]
but but don't sit here and act like you
know when somebody buys a switch is a
they get a red bandana they didn't do
this
listen here's thought this was done
before all the people that were going
Nintendo's gonna be third party there's
no more making games they're gonna be
subtly making games for Microsoft and
for Sony and Xbox biggie game for
Nintendo God when I touch the switch I
had it in my hand I knew exactly what it
was gonna do yeah you know I knew it was
gonna be as big as it's going to be um
but that that standstill switch this in
the box that's deal with you know that's
not a switch light that's not a switch
mini that's a standstill brother like I
said lordose box move you know saying we
used to play Ultimate Alliance back and
there's actually one of the first games
that got him into gaming you know saying
him cooperative so well you know it's
been over what ten years and whatever it
is and the franchise been gone so he got
a chance to set it up and get going but
I must admit getting the online set up
with Nintendo we just gave up and used
Xbox Live we just gave up we just live
talk you know oh yeah don't we don't get
a shot to Rick when yo [ __ ] just don't
glass all the day TMI cognate brother
mm-hmm get your top on forget your wait
whoa stuff that we take
stuff that's regular like oh my god my
cellphone can actually down numbers cell
phone has a Facebook okay King King we
got blue we got blue we went with the
superior online infrastructure of the
xbox live so this switch the way we
wanted you outta control
support the Emperor's him we allow
salute the raped world but yeah of
course that fire emblems you know say
cop that and we'll get into that with
that topic comes out and of course
they'll be rockin destiny but all that
good stuff overweight we got into what
the Lord's will plan I want to start
with Lord Nintendo guru his video game
system history his journey as a content
creator and of course what led him to
becoming a community manager for a game
studio soul of Bob let's start from the
very beginning what was some of the
first video game systems yeah what got
she negated I mean listen why I grew up
my grandparents owned a bar and I
started playing Donkey Kong in arcade
cabinet they had and then not long after
that my parents brought him an Atari
2600
I started playing that I had a boatload
of games and then the NES hits and I had
to beg my mom forever to get me one my
cousin's all got one she wouldn't get it
for us and then finally she you know me
my brother got good grades in school
which was a miracle in its own right and
she said
we'll get you one but it took us man
like six seven months after she agreed
to get us one cuz they were two sold-out
you couldn't get him anywhere and then I
would get what he did you get the
classic would you get robbed no no I got
that I got the zapper to duck-hunt I
think the actual said they call it head
Mario and and duck on in it Rob wasn't
really because when we went to the store
I convinced my little brother to get
Mike Tyson's punch-out mmm and I got
Zelda oh we went home that day and I
felt like I had the holy grail of you
know of greatness because I don't care
like to me I got it I'm like I'm sinking
right now with a coaster on my own my
thing Mike Tyson's punch-out like this
seems to me the best game in video game
history to make that's that I mean you
guys all grew up you know you know the
order of Mike Tyson and everybody wanted
to beat Tyson back then and they just
get to him yes what's one thing yes
until somebody found out the code to
code yeah six week I got a brat based
radio arcade $2.00 bad loves to the IOP
have a great show guys thank you so much
sir could tea I would hear more punch
out so you think of me back there I mean
like so for me I literally treated like
I was training to fight Mike Tyson thank
you legit took me I would say I went a
heavy nine months every single day I
come home from school and I go in I keep
putting the code in playing lose and
play and losing finally I beat him
alright and I I come out or I'm sorry I
did not come out I beat him by my
decision and I'm losing my mind and I
turn around and I'm like there's nobody
here to see that I did it and we don't
have like cell phones I can take a
picture of the screen or oh I can take a
picture of a CRT TV back you obey you
had a lights dim in the can
I'm like I'm screwed right so I like
grab the guy I get up I run out the door
I run down the street to my cousin's
house right I'm running down the street
knock on the door
my aunt answers door I'm like yeah let
me in what worried cuz this is my
brother and they're all in the back room
they're playing I come to a guy there's
my patient just feel like things like
Layton lady I'm like I swear to god I'd
be like do it now
oh dude you're going right and I'm
struggling who's the first one who's the
second one then I get into a rhythm and
I beat him but I beat him my decision
great I'm a heavy my family grew up
around boxing my grandfather I agree my
grandfather used to spar in the Bronx
they don't and Fort Apache we we look
he's bark I don't know what I don't know
what Jim was I know that he take LaMotta
used to always try to spar with him and
he said he wouldn't do it he refuses
it's priority colonic my uncle used to
spar Rocky Marciano Wow
they both were Golden Gloves boxers in
the Marines so my uncle comes walking in
the room right after every flipping out
because I just I just beat Tyson Oracle
to the screen he's like but you do not
come you mean but thank you
you keep me the champion by decision you
know and I'm like yeah I go restart the
game oh and I there and dude I am
hammering him like never before
touch me the first minute and 30 he's
stolen uppercuts I'm hitting them every
single time
Oh dodge game on fleek put him down TKO
him hey beautiful I beat the room like
flipping out now I go to school the next
day
mm-hmm to the cafeteria around a lunch
table I tell my boys Nathan you're lying
you didn't be
I had 10 people show up in my house
after school
yeah to show that I could do it dude I
had the room for I'm not have to be in
the house after school my parents are
home
I'm scared to death my dad's gonna come
driving up any second
it's the longest three minutes of my
life but I'm playing a depressive beat
him everything flipping out in the
bedroom I'm gonna get out everybody get
yeah I did it they get out the boss go
back greatest greatest time ever so yo
superstar after that for that trip
period time for about about three months
and then what do you early as far as our
punch out man
don't worry my question to you is from
the 80s we know that it is such a
classic system did you always stay in
line with Nintendo from that point on it
was was there ever a deviation was there
ever a time Sega or turbo Mia tempted
you to can't get a system a secondary
system I did okay so what happened for
me was I had the Super Nintendo who
loved the Super Nintendo and then
because sports games were so much better
on Genesis row
I bought a Genesis alright I wanted to
play but I would play Madden that I want
to play football the NHL you need a
child ok I got to get at you which one
would 93 94 the one with the blood the
one with the one with the name which one
I don't know which one of us is a
classic defense because for me back in
those days like Bulls worst Lakers well
those were the games throw Lakers versus
Celtics when the classic or the Pope in
through
at that point in time
anything that ei put out was legit
wasn't me any if you may put out was
legit sports talk football baseball they
were way ahead so for me at least for me
saying it was excelling in the sports
but as far as like Sonic and on another
trash I think that's to do they gave you
a run for your money here's a sonic when
you play Super Mario Brothers the first
one Miyamoto sense enough to teach you
how to play that game throughout the
whole thing
so you jump in Sonic and you're going I
gotta go fast I gotta run hundred miles
an hour and you pick through world 1-1
or whatever you want to call that
nonsense you gotta fly a hundred miles
an hour
hold on you got it dude you got a crazy
super chat oh yeah
dopey you guys are amazing keep up the
good work
welcome to Tendo guru switch love cog
addict King it's all dizzy hope you're
having a terrible time with your
convention and crate guard just really
that's all do pay me much for us one of
the writers almost came down a leader of
the screen tea army Laura so now though
thank you so much brother much
appreciated that amazing in you with
this yo little plumber was moving too
slow blasts master process question let
me go get some fanboy let's get one of
the greatest boxers Leonard all these
guys right they stand the test of time
they continue forever yes they're
considered to greatness right the green
Roberto durán promise earns Hagler oh
they're the greatest in that era right
but yet you have nobody else coming up
that does anything so when you have
Mario which is the gray
of all time whoa and it's still going
today oh I don't know man
like whatever it is right I'm going to
tell you Nintendo as a company did a lot
of smart moves but what was more
impactful what left a fanboy a serious
impression on you was when Genesis hit
they picked they peak when a Sega hit a
peak yeah when we get they peak with
that Dreamcast when they hit they peak
because that was the best console I
think to eight main period like as a
whole from the launch so what they gave
you when you opened it up it was the
greatest console I've ever opened up
period but when they put that foot on
Nintendo's neck for depression
Genesis does I go further quick I gotta
jump in here some real [ __ ] of
fanboy oh oh you guys I'm gonna read
this for you Brett save you like Duran
no oh damn Brad listen villain is in the
NES came III said I was an okay guy I
got this super master I mean the Sega
Master System because I was more in tune
with the same classic arcade but when
the Nintendo came I can out from you
guys had that that Mike Tyson punch-out
that's so the jealousy in me that I
didn't own that right so when now the
next two 16-bit era stars and Genesis
comes out with that aggressive marketing
you got the blast master for all this
but that was our time to talk we had the
blood in the morning so it was that was
our moment to finally get back at you
get a big long but I feel like honestly
this is the God's honest truth I feel
like that was probably the greatest time
of gaming because you did have that
aggressiveness like now you have all
three companies working together
and I don't get me wrong I get we're in
a new era and all that something I
always enjoyed that like back and forth
that argument that you know when you sit
around the lunch table and you're
arguing with your boys like what's the
best and what's not and like so for me
it's always been this and I loved it
like I like even the back-and-forth with
King I love it because I'm like man I
feel like I'm 15 years old
you know our conversations is a little
bit different right now is turned to
toxicity yes okay he said that he had a
Nintendo and you know he got his games
whatever and he brought a Genesis
because the sports games right yeah you
got some guys now that will look over
and see other games that they want to
play and refuse to purchase another
system out of weird loyalty to something
that doesn't exist the point right and
we can have these conversations because
if I couldn't afford a system and he had
a Genesis and I haven't know he was
coming over my house
what crazy stories we've always told her
ILP is like I said during my Genesis hey
and I'm feeling myself and King you know
during that time he would get the
Japanese imports so he would get the
Famicom super famicom or they would come
to the States
so he's like cog you gotta come over I
got a super famicom right so I'm like my
mom when I see the tender ooh let me
tell you right now
I scored F zero in pilot wings mode 7
for the first time I was like damn near
ran out of King's house on that super
famicom and some ice it was amazing mode
7 in my opinion changed again scaling
that graph it was just my mom because
again Genesis at that time was all our
blast proccesing side scroller kind of
stuff but what they were doing
technologically was really really next
level
I'm like I think see for me what I think
was so great about that era was Nintendo
was fine with the NES in their mind they
were like we can keep going with the NES
and because unless let's be truthful
here the foot was on the throat because
Nintendo wasn't moving up the 16-bit
yeah and and Sega was able to do things
because of the fact of like you're stuck
with the NES it you can't press anyway
so the difference is correct yeah so
eventually when it got to that point
where it was like okay we're gonna now
switch it up and we're gonna actually do
this this stuff it when they went to the
Super Nintendo man they finally brought
a system that was worthy because that's
what I love about Nintendo that Nintendo
wasn't afraid of the arms race yes
Nintendo won't get involved they'll just
think you know though they'll do what
they can do and don't be wrong I love
the I love the switch I love what it
does my man it would be nice to see them
just once go let's go let's go let's
let's just ramp it up and let's let's
show you what teraflops can really do
getting because that's the thing like
what they're capable of what they're
able to do with a little console like
that reach you imagine breath of the
wild and for bro dude they would kill it
and that's the thing like they are able
to because they come from the era of the
past
they are you tell me you tell me how
smash is only like 15 gauge and you
can't even put and and and there's
companies that can't even put doom on
the whole thing on one cartridge no
you're out because they are the kings of
compression man you know exactly what
they're doing and that's because of the
NES and the Super Nintendo they have
forced to learning different techniques
that other companies weren't and they
even we gotta even address like you know
before the CD era day what kind of
resistant all the way you know for a
while I mean they pretty much yeah you
know I'm saying and they were able to
still survive able to succeed and stuff
like that so um so pretty much you
stayed course all the way from my state
course I did get a dig in a Playstation
the only thing that made me get a
PlayStation was Final Fantasy 7 I was
running on the Super Nintendo and then
when they brew
my heart man it was like mom and dad got
a divorce where when Tony and I was like
this is not happening man and it did and
it happen and I would but I broke down
and I bought the PlayStation
I remember filling out a card they had
these cards and starts asking why you
bought the console and it was like I
bought it because of Final Fantasy 7 and
that was the only reason and I'm the
type of guy that like you know I'll buy
a console for one game yes I don't care
I don't want my crazy ex report for
Arkham Knight like I was like I gotta
have my I gotta have our completely I
love Batman I gotta have Arkham Knight
so I mean that for me that's the things
that get me hyped up like there are gate
like I bought my playstation 3 you know
for for less of us like that's the end
of the console like you don't work right
and then I went back and bought a whole
lot of other stuff too started playing a
bunch of other stuff cuz I was done you
know I I kind of gave up on gaming a
little bit like right around the
beginning of the ps3 and again cute at
the end of the game key where I was like
I'm done I'm not gonna mess with this
stuff no more mmm gotta be an adult kind
of grow up and be you know a spendable
person get a job then I was like no man
you know so what got you back I'm kid
what was the game when you made that
decision in life decision what was what
got you all the way back in the craziest
sounds the we dude though seriously I
went to my brother's house I didn't want
the week I said I'm not gonna sit here
because they showed and they were
talking about how Zelda you can like
pull the sword out and I'm like dude I'm
not doing that at the time I'm 30 years
old I'm like or 35 only no man like I
just want to play game I don't actually
being linked like that and so I was like
I'm done
I'm out and I went to my brother's house
he was in North Carolina he had some
buddies over and they brought to me and
I played Wii bowling and all that and I
was like this is insane like is this
really happening and then I went to go
get it and you couldn't get him they
were sold out you'll remember how hard
it was way dude I paid $500 that was
brilliant marketing yeah yeah really
scared
those two Japanese
he's going to people's house in October
we would like to play I was like that is
the coolest thing ever cook with my
house now I need one cup chopped my
house that's what got me back and then
man I plead Twilight Princess and galaxy
and I was like mmm I'm back I'm back in
a big bad way and that was it because
those amiibos would have missed you whoo
I got everything won every single one I
got a box blue one up there still in the
pocket Japanese import the things worth
like like his loving you setup they say
they love the lighting everything is the
setup like if you move over a little bit
you could see he has a logo that's right
behind his hat you guys my question do
you guys like spooky I like I mean we
can change the lane abuse for tuned
everyone like Mario makers a good thing
right we can go we know more you know
what I love that it is amazing I love
that love that
tremendous gaming history Wow
outstanding so go move on as far as like
that the community manager thing man you
are now the community manager for
between games so what led to that show
me opportuni and tell us for the people
who are not familiar with the thule like
where their focus is so to me is the
firmly renegade kid and that was a small
independent company that did stuff on
the 3ds on the ds1 we you they basically
started making these independent games
they did Mutant Mudds xeodrifter some
really phenomenal games moon was another
one the men tiem which is another one
you know that was on the 3d asset or -
yes they did some amazing things back
then and then
jewels watch them who's the owner of a
two E and Greg the video both partners
on renegade kid they decided good our
own weeks okay Jules basically was doing
the 2d stuff okay Greg was doing the 3d
stuff like the mentee and
and they decided like you take your you
take your toys you go that way you take
your toys you go that way but they were
so friends everything was it's
respectful and then I actually met Jules
through image and form I had become a
steam world ambassador basically I was
you know there was a contest I entered
if you guys watch any of the steam world
were not the engine room things they do
they're kind of like their Nintendo
Direct type things that they put out
that was my idea
oh wow that was how I won the contest to
get into the steam run ambassadors so
what the Ambassador Program entitles me
is every single game that launches from
from a major form I get for free every
console I get three car I get three
copies doesn't amount to who you know my
friends I'll be like hey go try this
game or whatever and the idea is to do
that for me to go like hey guys this is
a great game go check it out there you
go
so that's though few years ago they were
doing Mindy's at home and it was a
program and the antenna was trying to do
to get people up in you know checking
out Nintendo stuff then he's got an
image to form was there and Jules Watson
was there and I was like tweeting about
seeing Brian from uniform
oh my god I do Brian is up there do my
thing and then a couple days later
Jules follows me oh I was like wow okay
you know like I was the Guru at the time
and I'm like so I I sit there and I'm
like hey man this is what we're doing
over and I reach out the Jules could he
had said that he was like if anyone's
looking to review Mutant Mudds super
challenge Gary come out let me know and
I'll you know so I sent a tweet to me I
was like hey man I would love to review
it and he reaches back he's like here yo
I was like wow like at the time I was
still kind of small right and then I
said to him after I did a review he
liked to review a lot I did you know you
put a lot of thought into it you really
showed a lot of stuff you could put some
care into it thank you for that
and we just start talking us they came
in I got a podcast which like to come on
the podcast he's like absolutely and
came on the podcast everything went well
and then I was like hey Jules there's
some time to go and buy I think he made
a launch chicken wiggled not that long
you know and I said hey man I got a
podcast called if we're a Nintendo I
love I would love I would love if you
came over me and Shawn I said we're
talking about the topic I think was at
the time was about like the need for a
Nintendo this one the NX was announced
not was the need for a Nintendo to lean
on in these like hey the Indies
supporters you during the Wii U acts so
you know you should show the love back
rather than going kiss an eh button they
do exactly so Jules was like you know
come on and we had a very candid
conversation everything was great and
then Jules and Shawn start talking and
Jules goes on Shawn Shawn my people man
hey Julia another show you want to go on
Helen like really good friends and I do
this thing and I'm gonna tell you right
now man this is probably if a developer
gives you a coat the least you can do is
email them the day their game launches
just wish them good luck I hope you I
hope your game does really well good
luck today I do that for every single
person that gives me codes that I did I
have a relationship like all the times
it's not really the owners or whatever
whoever might be but like if someone I
start to build a little relationship
with I do with it but your form I do it
with wink I do it with a tool now now
now hey I don't do a thank you myself no
I would still say we're I still you know
message tools and say hey man today
today we're doing something to you know
good luck where they would everybody
just be genuine man like it's not
butt-kissing it's not nothing that
you're just being it'd be no different
if you guys did something right and I
was like hey man good luck today I hope
you kill it yeah I mean like that's all
you're doing
genuine the genuine attitude
ultimately built a relationship you guys
gonna shatter one bad mother-- with the
file super check look I love the day
this show always [ __ ] the best
old-school gaming memories thanks for
keeping gaming positive and fun yo my
brother that meant so much thank you
one bad mother-- may have really meant a
lot that's what we trying to do that's
the mission of the lords couldn't change
me Lord attend so my thing was was I
came in I got this great relationship
building with these guys and then Jules
came to me or I went to Jules we had a
discussion when they could just get on
calls he would call me up and go hey man
I got this new thing coming out what do
you need show me it was yeah and he
would be like what do you think about
this and I like this maybe try this
whatever and then I say I know he's
doing it and I'm like holy crap man like
he considers what I'm saying to be
Howard your input your feedback well
then we started a show together called
behind the scenes with Jules watching
yes and it was kind of like a like a
director's cut on DVDs we were taking
these old games that he worked on bring
him in and we would like play footage
and talk about so he did I wind up
separating from my wife and I needed
just I didn't know what's going on or
get ready to go through a divorce I was
leaving my house all this stuff and I
went to all my shows everybody that was
doing stuff with and I said I can't do
anything for a while I don't know what
I'm gonna be back Jules is one of those
people
we had candid conversations these guys
all had my back they all supported me
they should be loved it was amazing
that's what's up
I left Lou Becky with my mom for a
little bit of time and when I did Jules
reached out to me like a couple weeks
later and hey man I'm going to III hmm
what do you like I got a I got a sweet
two queen-size beds would you be willing
to come with me because you pay your way
you get out there too bro
I'm like I'm there man I'm there so I
went out we had a great time you know
like it was unbelievable that was your
first entry rc350
the first one fantastic it was amazing
amazing so got to meet all these people
got to be
people from yacht club from Nintendo
because the connections with Jules he's
introduced me to everybody he's treating
me like I'm somebody that's what I mean
so I come back I wind up moving into
this place I bought this place set it up
get off get running and Jules kind of
had some issues on social media and
people start attacking and other stuff
and he kind of walks away from social
media okay
and about three weeks ago he just read
the whole time we still communicate you
know we stop show we stopped doing the
show because of that all that stuff and
you know we he reaches out to me he says
hey man I got this thing I want to talk
to you about okay he reaches out to me
and he says I know that I need to have
something going on here I have to have
somebody come in and kind of direct the
ship social media wise I love what your
community does I love I've been watching
you for a couple years now
I like how encouraging and how you
invite people in you're willing to help
people with your with their stuff would
you please come in and you know run my
community Wow I was like dude yes no
problem yes I was like humbled beyond
belief because as a little kid I mean I
think we can all can really relate to
this some level I've said whatever your
dream is you should kitchen table with
your buddies and you just talk about
like man I would love to do this one day
mm-hmm and I went from wanting to meet
it I was wanting to meet someone that
makes video games and to someone that
wanted to go to e3 Oh someone I wanted
to do something working with video games
oh and I was able to do all that within
the past few years not because of not
because of anything other than the
community that was built that bro is
here right now like right here in the
chat right now this is your community
yes you guys are nothing without them
absolutely people here that are throwing
up super chats and and just here just
you got 41 likes on the street right
that is they don't realize you are you
are helping these guys grow and that
what it ultimately boils down to
it's down to what you you get what you
give you kindness you know we live in a
world where it is so easy to jump on
Twitter and just harass people what does
he get you nothing nothing at all well
one minute and you show a little love
and it changes life men eyes know about
Brooklyn from New York Etica took his
life yeah that moment changed my life in
terms of what I do around here mm-hmm
every day or at least four times a week
I will stop and I will tweet to some
content creator and say you're doing
good work yeah I think you've said that
that is important in our community oh
yeah because again there's content
creators that are so passionate and
sometimes you'd be surprised if a larger
content creator or even anyone on the
same side just acknowledges them just
says yo you know what that video you did
was outstanding
that is so important because so many
people need that day they were on the
cusp right they don't know and it's like
I'm so glad you said that but guru you
be my motivation to do this right and
this is what I think people from the
outside don't recognize you guys want to
hit you guys when it's a super chat yet
again really love this show love the
environment love this community love the
iron Lords salute brothers yes for me
the one thing I could say is I don't
like to Philly the people in chat right
now you know realize that like we all
eat sleep drink
this the community did the content
creating if I'm sitting here and I'm
like this this is all I see is the
microphone that's all I can like see I
don't see what's going on around me I
think people like what I'm doing but I
don't know because I'm so close to the
content I can't see beyond so you get
that one stupid tweet and it's not
really stupid I'm just saying you get
one tweet and it's like hey man I loved
what you're doing it thank you for your
doing dude it changes your day you could
get you guys could get let's let's be
honest you guys get 60 super chats today
and that's amazing
and that means the world but man you get
that one tweet oh this is hey man I
liked what you did on this one video and
it changes your whole card cards to jump
on that point cog showed me DM someone
sent him I think was like a week and a
half ago [ __ ] and it was so touching
yeah yeah and you know he didn't want to
put it out there or whatever he was like
I hope it reaches King and I read it and
I had a reflection moment yeah that you
know because you know a lot of that you
see y'all see the statues and stuff that
I put up and cog is like you know he
gets highly upset when it doesn't do the
numbers that he thinks that it's
supposed to judge my brother work and I
know sometimes I said there are five six
I was working on the video too until I
get it right right so like at the sound
or whatever I'm looking for or whatever
feel that I'm trying to get to but when
I look at it and I see the likes and I
see comments at the bottom because I try
to answer every last comment absolutely
when when I see that and somebody says
yo I didn't know saber-toothed was this
or this was that you taught me something
that I didn't know mmm
I'm so pleased with I'm so happy about
that
mmm and it's a good feeling to know that
you know somebody appreciates the
whatever hard work you do I don't care
if it translates the million you know
views or whatever I just it's just that
one person oh my god yes save it to was
my
every character and yeah oh yeah can I
get this from I help you I could tell
you we even go and all that other stuff
real good feeling to your passion is
coming across to somebody on the other
side absolutely shouted actor the file
is super shy I'll be cruel much love
thank you for the enjoyment every Sun be
again thank you so much brother really
really means a lot man it's integral you
guys got me tearing up right here man
it's real man I'm so glad you said it
you know me because it's important I
just want to touch briefly two more
questions and we get more than you don't
saying but I'll make them quick I'll
make it quick I won't tank for carry on
what you said you know my personal note
obviously you know I want to talk about
that recent video you did was very
inspiring and it would really hit home
for me
in reference to gamer health and
specifically you haven't encouraged to
put your journey out there to the world
so the question I have for you is like
what since then what have you learned
from that experience and then what
advice would you give to game was like
in reference to their health to physical
well so I think I think what I learned
from it is a it's you don't realize the
people you're touching when you actually
do it I put that out there for me
mmm-hmm for other people and it sounds
silly to say that because it's like well
why did you put it up on YouTube oh yeah
I mean but I did it because I wanted to
try to hold myself accountable
mmm-hmm let me put this out there
because it'll just kind of resonate you
know I mean and the amount of people and
the support that came off of that was
unbelievable like it's just it's crazy
look I just read something in the chat
that was sound like YouTube and Twitter
will always be you know toxic just block
them but it's like man the love that was
shown over that was unbelievable and so
I think that like it's just a matter of
you know it's just a matter of basically
you know you just got to do what you got
to do and have the courage to put it out
there and not be afraid what people
think because ultimately works on you
and then as far as like for gamers and
health and stuff like then you got to
put yourself first
absolutely like I said Oh like I learned
a lot from the Etica situation mm-hmm
what I learned from that I actually took
a break that weekend I had been going
full-bore non-stop non-stop since last
August and literally I was putting up
five videos a day mmm
so I'm working a full-time 50 hour a
week job come home I would come home at
five o'clock and I wouldn't stop until
midnight content podcasts everything
right and I just got to the point where
I was like I'm starting to hit a wall
and when I saw what happened it just it
spoke to me in terms of like man you got
to worry about number one first hello
and you're no good to anybody if you
don't worry about yourself and so I just
I just started to say to myself like I
need to look at things and do things
because if I'm not around what good's it
to anybody in that side and I'm not just
talking my community I'm talking about
cash right there Lord addict please
unmute your mic because this is the kind
of stuff that I was trying to talk to
addict my brother and I'm saying we're
not gonna put no lies personal business
out there it's just that at the end of
the day you know I'm saying like he was
going to some physical stuff and I was
just saying bro at the end of the day we
want you around you know that so if
you're good to no one if you're not a
lot it up say and I'm glad you said that
is so important you know saying continue
oh and we got ground a game on my board
really
Lord you guys are truly a very positive
beacon of light in the community gaming
community keep doing what you do keep
doing your thing really this home mom
always hope people can reach out to the
next person before anything stupid reach
out yes you had a Lord Steyn brother I
lost vision could really see what people
don't understand it really touches
everyone all right everyone did you come
in contact
it affects and if he if you haven't a
moment you down you know um there's
always somebody that you can connect to
if you can't connect to somebody hey
reach out to me I'm telling you I'm on
me I'm gonna try to give you a positive
day I'm gonna try to you know give back
to you but always reach out before you
do anything that you can't take back
mmm thank you shop fatty fatty fatty he
said at this red light summing the Guru
I don't even play a Nintendo but I got
it
now let me drive my I know pulls all but
I'm trying to keep it together
awful things like oh man you have no
idea man what a journey what a story man
oh you here's somebody who and I'm glad
you're saying what you're saying please
I put his on description I'll keep
putting it in the chat you know please
come up to the Guru this guy's positive
like I said one of my favorites find him
through stealth and I was just like man
I kind of like girl at least somebody
does we get you out in for the interview
portion as far as we got to ask this
question it's just to every guest here
in the realm of the Lord's I need
Nintendo gurus top five video games or
franchises of all time of all time
that's not difficult one I already
talked to Mike I was my number one
number two would be the original Kid
Icarus mm-hmm number three is a Link to
the Past mmm number four is Last of Us
hmm and and number five would be would
be breath in a wild it moves up because
like for me Zelda get one take this
man's a Nintendo car addict complain
it's not breath of the world I could
tell you that I should link to the past
as my in my opinion the best game of all
time
try to come to me with some Majora's
Mask stuff but actually like I can't
really like say that any of them are bad
or any of them are better than the other
one but I can honestly say that breath
of the wild it's not one of the worst
outa's like but it's just like as far as
like how that would have found getting
it built it's one of the worst but we
want to tell you at it that I'm gonna
tell you to your face
alright Skyward Sword come on here's the
thing and I'll see this this is why
breathitt a wild rank so high for me
it's because this is Nintendo's first
true foray into an open-world game mmm
anybody want to play fallout
how long has has Bethesda they put now
you know in a day one patch that is
bigger than the actual game itself
[Music]
that's what 10 gig tops the only issue
with an entire game slow down that's not
there anything other than the stupid
Wi-Fi a patch two weeks later and the
game seamlessly King goodbye no statues
wife over my back looking salute Lords
keeping the community valid yeah listen
I hope you're using that option that you
can finance on sideshow I hope you yes
when I found out about that option
things really game I can't collect like
really expensive stuff like that because
I have a habit of
of a mess around crazy chicks that like
to throw things
oh so I can't be around like you know
plates want they they throw this kind of
statues King got first off I don't you
think half the chicks I mess around
could pick that stuff somehow she goes
hulk on my ass and she throws it at me
might kill me like you gotta worry about
that because if some I can't do get that
saber-tooth back there I might not be
able to pick that up so when I was when
I was when I was married
mm-hmm I had a bat cave that I call her
and I had Crete like I got I got a shoe
King I'll send you a picture King on the
side what it used to look like right
yeah I had life-size bust of the Joker I
know you talked about the one with the
flower right yes yes okay $700 that baby
boo be back right tells me like ever you
mana you I'll go down there with a
baseball bat boy hey I said that'll be
the last thing you ever do so you better
have one that dead bus that bus was
probably the best depiction of art like
Joker
it wasn't me like from like a key Heath
Ledger or anything like it was actual
like a cartoon that they brought it to
life when I saw the flower and the
clothing they told the cloth the
mixed-media on the bust yes the creepy
head tilt smile look at my eyes boy that
is probably one of the best bus the
sideshow ever put up yes those with a
five we got the five end we got those
five games in it that's it good let's
get his show Rowan cannot talk about
last week's poll results in the people
spoken to the question with a gears 5
multiplayer tech test out in the wild is
your gameplay experience positively or
negatively affects your enthusiasm for
the game on release
the winner of a very close three-way ILP
poll at 46% was that I don't care where
the campaign footage at though I missed
my slaughter of slow-mo unless global I
was disappointed in that man something
that went on that we had to get
clarification about yeah you know
somebody was saying that he got
slaughtered and I'm like what happened
and I'm like what's going on let's go -
now the Lukesh of snow looking exactly
what she was doing putting it in that
well exactly with 38% of the vote was
the 4k 60 goodness gears fires head
cardigan five has made me a believer on
launch group and come in at last place a
60% of the vote ones don't
gears as your servers and wait times
more horrible group shout out to over
hundred 50 loads who participated in the
poll Lord sovereign just real quickly
what did you think about the petit Lords
I told you petit Lords win I'm in the
Boosters all I care about is the story I
don't give my man a shout out like we're
rigging the vote in the Kings chat we
see you basement ready okay we know you
have something to do it's gonna be a big
show all right Nintendo's Tokyo Drift
Thank You come up with that little
clever girl love you more now because of
the fallout 76 dislike we had the
obviously droidcon issue going on and in
a class action lawsuit was filed so on
we know this was very intentional at the
whole law with the breakdown but um yes
since then Nintendo has responded and
I'm saying they've made a statement in
reference to what's going on and pretty
much it was more to less than less to
the fact that you go to
customer support page and you can um
actually you know fill out the actual
link to the joy con issue specifically
and then you made a statement we take
great pride in creating quality products
we have continuously making improvements
to them we are aware of the recent
reports that some joint con controllers
are not responding correctly we want our
consumers to have fun with Nintendo
switch if anything falls short of this
goal we will encourage them to the visit
support that Nintendo comm blah blah
blah so now that this news is out a
Nintendo head respond let's start with
the Guru let's get him in on this you
Dino you did a good video talking about
this issue I know a lot of us didn't
believe it was to the extent it was but
I have that issue Wow hey I didn't think
it was to the issue it was let's be fair
let's be a little fair nobody even
talked about drifting until they
announce which light and they saw that
the the sticks were the identical to the
joy cons right because then people were
like well now what happens right so
nobody even realize the amount of
drifting and I think it was one of those
things of like it was happening to
people but people didn't really think
anything about it
once they announced the switch like it
blew up I put a pole on if we're a
Nintendo Twitter and then we also looked
at like Nintendo Life did one and it was
like 50% of people we're saying that
like hey I have a drift issue my left
one doesn't yeah it's the left one it's
the one that it's basically that's the
one that's basically doing it I didn't
you know I think that the thing if it
was under warranty then I was fixing it
no problem but they were charging four
dollars for shipping whatever if it was
out of warranty they were charging
people to fix it yes and that's where
the issue was starting to arise I think
once they got with of the class-action
lawsuit hey number one we're gonna have
to do this regardless gonna make us do
this so we must jump on to it and do it
now but I think it's what brought it to
light and I think it's like what are
those things are like where hey you're
getting you're getting calls to the
customer service call center but how far
is it going up the chain and I think
once the class-action started happening
I think wait a minute this is an issue
we need to fix this so
if they are fixing it and they're
basically saying what they're telling
people is if you have an issue call us
we will fix it
free of charge and then if you have paid
to get it fixed let us know and we'll
reimburse you the money not paid to do
it so they are doing the right thing
ultimately this super chair is going to
us adding in better debate skills
oh I don't curb stomp a dude and not
help them up that's fine at the end of
the day slow mo yo chat was on my side
that's not even my show what it is you
can you can you can give us more money I
would gladly we will take that money but
at the end of the day your chest said I
won yo chat not mine so you're gonna
have to take that and just sit down join
Khan drift yeah I mean it's a Nintendo
product like I'm used to that like
almost every generation it happens
sooner or later enjoy kind rift happened
to every every time I place a generation
I don't think it happened on the
Gamecube mm-hmm I don't think it
happened on the Wii U I don't you know
if it could happen on the Wii U and I
don't think it could happen on the
Nintendo it happened on the n64
like almost every other generation it
happens I mean whatever issues that they
have first they debuted a lot even so so
in general how do you feel about um
Nintendo's handling of it do you feel
like they were pressured because the
lawsuit do you are you upset
like where you at with how they handle
this issue I think it's funny that you
know that they say something after they
get there they get that boot to the neck
because I don't think I would have said
ice everyone would have just uh you know
it's fine we don't need we'll just go by
seventy eight seventy eight dollar ones
they'll okay that's fine no one make any
statement Oh tell the community manager
not to make that statement they're fine
they're fine it's a very much you they
dig the class-action lawsuit is what you
feel yeah we throw five more bucks at
him to teach him how to be if they need
a class-action lawsuit to get things its
foot in lines and doing it like who
can't like if you're having issues hmm
it should be recall well to that extreme
and it looks like it's a large portion
of people I had it I have it my cousin
storm has it like it's not just like one
or two people it's a good percentage of
the switched units well I mean if your
question let me ask you a question this
is a serious question you you you said
you had the issues you and your cousins
and all that stuff
did you call Nintendo no because I
didn't care like I don't know so what
I'm saying is ultimately what I feel is
yes people had issues but going on the
internet and complaining is one thing
and actually contacted the company and
saying hey I have a problem people did
contact the company and they know where
they were fixing them they would have
charged him a repair fee they said in
that stay under warranty but they said
in that statement that if you were
charged for repair fee you were getting
refunded so they were charging people it
was out of warranty that's what I said
beginning it was out of warranty then
yes that's how businesses work thank you
listen if this mouse pad stops working
after three years apples not going to
fix it but if it's within warranty
that's how businesses work all the new
it so at the end of the day now they're
going back and going hey we recognize
that this is a problem we're
fix it properly until people actually
started getting involved with it like I
said tell us which light blues and that
is the warranty on a switch a year about
you yeah now real quickly uh before I
get solid Oh what did you ask about did
you guys see the song did you see any of
the litigation of verbage no I read a
paragraph we got caught it was quite
hilarious Oh defended which manufactured
wood meeting in Tendo which manufactured
marketed and sold to switch enjoy Kahn
controllers is aware of the defect
through online consumer complaints
complaints made by the consumer to
defendant through its own pre-release
testing then it's subject 3 yet
notwithstanding the knowledge of the
manufacturing defect defendant fails to
disclose the defect in retreat or
retreat only routinely refuses to repair
the joysticks without charge when the
defect manifests and never disclosed
this material defect to consumers to the
last boy as a result of the defendants
unfair deceptive and fraudulent
practices owners of switches including
plaintiff sucky ascertainable loss of
money and our proper value there as a
result the joint destroy con DIF defect
and the monetary costs associated with
attempting to repair the game consoles
plaintiff and the class have suffered
injury in fact incurred damages and
otherwise have been every day if things
aren't brought up on social media
nine times out of ten a company ain't
taking us seriously there's just not
like you've got looking for the Bethesda
situation for so fall at 76 if everyone
would have just called they they could
their customer service and left it there
and didn't take to Twitter but then some
would be in the situation there are now
they would be fine because no one is
blasting them on Twitter that is
literally that is below one voice people
have if they got a Twitter account that
at Bethesda was enough times a thousand
to get Bethesda's attention yes like a
year warranty that's not a lot mm-hmm
I got this
warranty from the store that you
purchase it from in conjunction with the
warranty there yeah I don't have a best
buy around me that I couldn't even do
that
but the day like you got to look at it
like how many millions of switches are
in the wild right what do you think
about it right I'm sorry about 2,000
people tweeting about it that's not a
lot of people but that's still enough of
a voice to get a class-action lawsuit
that mo carried around to get people in
the class action lawsuit from social
media that's how I get what you're
saying
but what I what I mean is if people
don't contact the company and say I have
a problem right then they can you're not
like most of the people that voted that
they had problems I bet you added those
50 percent like to defend released in a
poll 2,000 people voted essentially a
thousand people said they had a drift
problem I bet you less than five percent
actually contacted Nintendo yes because
most of the time when it comes to
hardware she's like that they just at
that point leads up to you Nintendo has
the best customer service ever
if you call them up do they will help
you with anything have you ever worked
in any type of customer service related
issues I worked at Best Buy
they worked I worked at Dish Network
I took calls of these people calling 80%
of these people didn't even want to call
a lot a bunch of them think that you
there's nothing that we can even really
do like there is a huge disconnect in
terms of customer service like that
where people don't even think calling is
going to help mmm listen back wrap for
the two hours of a chat being very petty
more switches in the rap your anti uh
Microsoft at this point but I'll let me
say I am the ultimate fraud because my
switch could be drifting to death
upstairs right now I have actually
so until they get some original content
that I like that I want to play I will
find out about my drift and I will join
that this is an original this is an
original we talking about I'm sorry this
is true the fire a balloon because it
has amiibo support I will be supporting
it sir this thing you could good games
constitute amiibo support that was right
there that when you go to it they're
like and this is where you go to use
roomy both unlike I've even looked at
man I did almost like I was at work so I
couldn't post about almost if I would
have been at home I would have
screenshot and like there's cheap of the
system what they promised me when I
purchased it is said amiibo support I
want that so that's what exactly made
all those statues using the gun she
cooked GTA ok BAM I got guns we gonna
figure out what he gives me and I'm
gonna be happy you know how much joy and
ores I got be a hundred percent positive
but as kid I think King has said he
wasn't messing with the game cuz I had
no amiibo support yeah there's something
related to that
look we got we got a giddy because we
got you gotta get another topic you but
I gotta get solved real quickly to kick
so solve your whole thing Nintendo drift
Jory Caron situation I mean I'm never
the one to condone people ganging up on
anybody just to make a point but um you
know Nintendo always been the type of
company that yes their customer service
is fantastic I rarely ever had a problem
with any of their products
I've never had any drift on my joy con I
don't know but the fact that they're
being as soon as that lawsuit came out
they're like oh hold up we're changed
well like I've never seen Nintendo
companies gonna tell you like you're
gonna take what we give you and you're
gonna like it cuz I am you gotta press
them like yeah yeah an opinion president
as as a proud Puerto Rican American who
saw the mother country recently
out there the governor just like
standing there and just like forcibly
getting him out twerking him out of the
other day this isn't going to help now
here now you know they're gonna do their
little bit a little trade ends well okay
here's your switch leave me alone but
this is gonna help as you know that's
which - well okay okay I want you to
make sure that don't happen again
I don't feel like doing with this
nextgen make sure that don't happen
again
like it's just it's amazing to me that
when it's used for something like this
to make a company address something that
maybe they thought wasn't as serious as
it actually is
i I I'm told I'm in total agreement with
it and I mean I hope they this gets
retracted now that they're addressing
the issue I hope the point of it was to
get them to address the issue in this in
this across the board type of way and
they sort of retract this and it's not
an issue I don't really think like a
lawsuit maybe a little too far but you
know it got the point across it's like
look like if you sell us defective
products and everyone tells you we will
press you systems has had a fatal flaw
yeah no red ring of death and this is
not as egregious as that but the fact
that Nintendo bent the knee heard of it
as soon as he got when the paperwork
came onto the table I'm pretty sure yeah
all those for free please thank you I
mean this is why I say Nintendo has one
of the best customer services when the
when the joy Khan's first came out the
left to a community nervous I even lied
you go until you
it wasn't working when that when a left
recon was dying on people getting a DSS
they fixed it they addressed it when you
go back to the we right when you played
other end if you played other and how
many people played it because was a bad
game but right yeah when you went to a
certain area you block that you could
lock your game up there was a bug in the
game that you can lock the game up
they couldn't advance couldn't do
anything because we put on as a joke on
backwards
Tendo recognized it and said send us
your seat your memory card we'll fix it
and send it back to you don't charge it
they've since the beginning of Nintendo
they've always been pretty good with
customer service it might take them a
while sometimes to pick up on this and I
think the lawsuit was I think it was
just ambulance chasers honestly we've
gotten around to this at some point
right probably not as quickly as people
wanted them to but I think to be fair
like I said in the beginning until the
switch light was announced they had I
don't think anybody had any idea how big
of a problem that was switch light got
announced and then all the drifting kids
I mean the reason I you know got so much
attention there is because like look
like first off these things are not
cheap these joy counts or not I don't
like you know maybe later generations of
I'm assuming they they've at least
remade these to some point I don't know
it's like the new because I'd like the
blue and red ones so I'm sure you know
since it's one of the first ones that's
the reason mine did it this blue one
definitely probably almost all of them
do it
but it's just like I guess where I
played so many handhelds and I've had
issues with handhelds sooner or later it
was not an issue and I don't play any
like hardcore first-person shooters or
anything like that on the switch so like
it's never really an issue most of time
I can use I don't even think these are
called deep like we're pad but you know
I can use that and it's equivalent like
sometimes I have to like press out a
little bit because it keeps going up and
down on the menu right you know Steven
crazy I don't even use those stupid
little things and I you right yes a cues
that you can't use with the mini
mmm moving along keg are you good you're
ridiculous
you feel everything majestic honey right
now what do you say Doug Doug Doug
mousers like puckered up it was like oh
wait did you see the video they put out
though nice he was talking to the camera
and slowly was like sliding to the left
laughing at your pain yeah anyway their
lawsuit hit the table free happen so
shut up listen y'all can see right now
right don't let it get too bad if
anything goes wrong with something you
got you out of warranty then once you
pay for it soon don't protest what and
pork in front of their building they're
like oh man they brought lawyers in it
go ahead and settle give them what they
want just get off my desk
all the Lords of Dale did I mean
obviously I didn't like the initial
silence Nintendo regarding issues were
glad it's being address customer support
is on it you know I'm saying they giving
it to you all you gotta do is pay for
the shipping you know I definitely a fan
of this approach kind of like what the
whole red ring at that situation
obviously not as egregious as that but I
liked it they just jumped in front of it
because I remember when uh
what's-his-name Peter Moore talking
about
speaking of Steve farmer during that
time not easy to go to someone like
Steve Ballmer saying you billion-dollar
yeah Chad they're ready for me she said
they'd get her joy cards now but um yeah
so I mean what those those are moments
that you got to see how like you handle
it and it's you take that hit and you
say look we got to get in front of it
and hopefully with the future iterations
of the switch to one with an extended
battery life and the light hopefully you
know those issues are resolved but we
got to move on content early we got much
time when I'm left but I wanted to get
this topic in with him which is a soft
topic um myself if you could modify
slightly I know we we got both cuz we
got emblem
without Youngblood right I want to know
if we can modify a little bit focus more
emblem first okay cool I know I don't
addict it probably played more emblem
than I have seen ours and yeah yeah okay
talk about that let's get it the
appearing I don't game with yet so
what's going on so so let me introduce
it and then add a kit you've been the
weeds with it yeah go for it so first
fire and if I have emmalin three houses
the first firing emblem to come to you
know quote-unquote consul in in quite
some time since the GameCube everything
else has been sort of on portable so far
emblem um and it is an an amazing game
and this is coming from a guy who's
never really been that big into strategy
RPGs mm-hm but this is man Wow as a
starting off point it's great because it
it it you don't necessarily have to have
played the older games to be invested in
this so the story of three houses is
basically this um basically it's kind of
like Harry Potter basically you are you
you are basically tasked to join one of
three particular houses within a school
that is basically taught to they
basically taught to fight right they're
being trained to go out and fight and
once you choose one of these houses
basically you you you you become a
teacher you train your students you also
improve your own stats in order to go
out and fight eventually what happens is
story wise is that everything there's
like a time time leap forward and
basically all the people that were
you're friends with in this monastery
with you all you guys were all learning
which is basically the monasteries risk
like like Hogwarts Hogwarts
yeah now they're your enemies now
something has happened in the interim
that all of these people that you were
once close with are now except the ones
in your own house are basically your
enemies now and what for me
the tactical stuff that the combat stuff
I'm still trying to wrap my head around
because I haven't played Fire Emblem in
such a long time but for me that the
thing that drew me to this game more
than anything is that details in the
story stuff there
so much action-rpg in that it's kinda
it's nuts did you get to where you read
break the tongue no haven't done that
yeah I literally I it's I'm glad you
said that
cuz I was gonna be real gonna try to get
to that part first cuz I literally just
got to the part they're like let's come
back here five years oh I didn't get to
that so I don't know I'm not gonna spoil
anything in that regard but the thing
about it is what I've seen so far like I
said for me as just a classical RPG fan
is that they've added so much of that
into this game stuff you can do at the
monastery when you're not in class when
you're not actually learning when you
could just walk around and roam the
monastery and just do side missions and
stuff like that there is so much of that
it's kind of ridiculous I've never seen
this in a fireman game before this is
overwhelming it is it definitely is it
there's so much that you can do but it
all goes back to two things and making
you care about the characters so that
when this time leap happens and you have
to Merc these people it really hurts you
wait and you know I really like that
that the outlet Alliance the yellow ones
yeah I like the main character a lot so
I have a feeling when I come up to me
like man are you sure you don't want to
just come over here I'm not sure but I'm
I'm thinking that like the leaders of
each one the egg the three main
characters that you meet early on I
think those regardless of what you know
you're gonna have to kill the other two
but I think at some point you are able
to recruit people that were from other
houses but it's just gonna depend on
what stats you've boosted up to be able
to get them to come to crossover like
and that's that's another thing like
depending on what you choose to focus on
stat-wise yeah it'll open up different
avenues for you to be able to bring
different people into your fault and
other ones won't even be available or be
super difficult to do depending on what
your stats are so like I said like for
me just the the core RPG mechanics apart
from the battle stuff is what really has
me drawn in because they
they they really they they threw the
kitchen sink into this they really did
let's get up get Attic fish and we gotta
get up girls don't you know what I
really like about this game gives me a
huge Final Fantasy Tactics feeling like
I don't know like this is the only game
that beats the original tactics wow
that's huge
because that story from tact it's like
you know shout out to who was it that
you sing that sweet
Oh shall we do a stealth for you yes
Stella 40 like he put on there he you
could ask for kognito before the podcast
I even said it was I feel like this
church a little bit south man some go
ahead to the point where you know I'm
pretty sure that church is gonna I'm
pretty sure after that gap the church is
gonna be the enemy I don't know but
we're gonna have to see because it gives
me that that feeling that because in
tactics that's what happened
right you know tactics was way worse
than that everyone turned out to be the
enemy in tactics but you're so I really
Joy's I enjoy the the combat you know
they they got that class system but it's
different and I have like that school
thing into it I feel like this is about
a better persona 5 mm I like persona but
I didn't like the school stuff yeah you
like school stuff here because range
well done here
when I come up to you know I finally I
had like a 33% chance to upgrade the
leader of my house to an armored unit
and it passed and because it passed I
literally I used this because the only
thing that would hurt her was archers
archers and mages what majors really so
I used to send an archer with her just
an archer to kill the mages and she she
would come up to like six people and she
just put her shield down and they would
come up one at a time and she would just
kill them out cuz how it works is it's
like a cause and reaction when I hit
them it reacts to it an attack back so I
literally just sit her in the middle of
an entire RV and one by one these
dummies will come up and try to clap her
and she would just drop that acts on
them over and over again it's oh they're
all dead like oh let's get look at the
Guru in man cuz we can seize that let me
tell some Google emmalin's out did you
pick it up and then yes we bit high
surely with this game of the year top
game of the Year let's let's put a pin
in a hog break we still have some stuff
coming on me because it'll probably be
Nintendo's Game of the Year okay you
know probably the game that Nintendo
pushes and probably does get nominated
when everything goes on I don't know
that anything is good depends on what
like death stranding and all that other
stuff that's gonna be in the mix but
it's definitely there in the mix the
thing with the thing is I'm curious
about these guys are you playing with
permanent death or no yes I'm playing
like the first five matches like how
this game reacts is in tactics if
someone fell you had turns to get them
up before they were quote-unquote gone
on here it's like if they drop zero done
yes I mean I think as you progress in
the game
you do get ways to be able to turn back
time a little bit and be able to avoid
some of that I I just found that out too
two fights ago I began this whole game I
know I could do that
and what's why as you guys slow card me
you know like once you get that short on
people you're pretty much like a
jehovah's witness at that point can you
please join us please join us like that
swipe play without it on cuz i just want
to enjoy the game in the story right but
i like then it gives you it's also like
two different difficulties and it lets
you play that way and we're not the
hardest difficulty exactly how I feel
cuz addict likes to play on the most
unimaginable gradients difficulties ever
in games
I used a difficult game conqueror and I
use amiibos what king I'm sitting here
support for items now I'm going to best
buy what you said that there's a me both
characters can be used you're gonna see
I'm gonna put a video of all these guys
coming off the shelf because they
ready for war just like I did with my
breath or the fire breath for a while I
had a whole table I showed my Wow REM
you get ready to rock 12 out 1 people
what I really like about the game is
like on tactics you'd have three turns
if you didn't they would be dead on here
zero they're dead but the difference I
hear between their tactics tactics unit
they outnumbered you but not by much it
was like you know you're they always at
least had like three or four more people
sometimes if you go on here and
permadeath is completely [ __ ] of your
team it's gonna be three on one and I
sit here I'm like all right I'm like I
have this Pegasus chick that's on a
flying horse and I'm like you suck
you're sitting over here in this corner
you could watch everyone else do
everything else you're not moving
you need a change this class sucks but
I'm like alright and then some people
like the archers I will keep them in the
force the whole game it's like you don't
move from here because I can't have you
die
riders are typically the best across
them but their Pegasus was like but the
thing is this scheme is
paper-rock-scissors
though each thing is gonna outclassed
the next not as much as it used to be
good no you know okay you know how the
paper-rock-scissors like like like
stored be like ax b sword or that's not
yeah it sort of been eliminated that
armored unit takes everything it really
does like it so they've sort of
eliminated that where that's not the
what I find now is that difference in
terrain yeah the important was they get
guy told me to get in the woods and wear
whatever and you could kind of be
stealthy and I noticed my vision was up
when I have like nine units in they're
good to you so then but I like for me
what I like about this is it reminds me
of feats I was so afraid that with this
one I was gonna have to buy three games
but I was glad the way they kind of did
this one fates I did by three years and
I liked it where was this very similar
where you go in you hit the point it's
like okay now pick where you want to go
and then you went out you pick the team
you want to go and go it's similar to
this like you pick your house and then
you go and when when I picked the house
like I kid you not
it was it was a hard decision I I didn't
want the blue dude that dude I ain't
care about it yeah but I sit there
looking at the red in the yellow he was
me Yahoo's they're like yeah yeah I like
I like to make character I like you he
throws it to a brother's out like he's
crazy the main character the illogical
like his charisma
I liked the cockiness of the of the
chick from the red one yeah who do gets
on my nerves like every time I see him
like when we do those like he's too
noble like yeah every time we use those
those house battles during the Academy
I'm like blue going up first no way
what's cool what I like about is when
you do those big battles and it small of
the house is fighting each other
I'll be sitting by I have like my two
big biggest people in the front everyone
else in the back of my co just yeah I'm
just gonna yellow and blue just just
have it out I think the thing that I
like it best about this is in previous
fireman games like when you would go to
your battle it would kind of like be
top-down and all that stuff this does a
swooping thing that makes you feel like
it's a bigger bag yo it's more immersive
like where and the other one she would
pick like one character and it felt like
it was this character and this character
fighting but when you actually it swoops
down you realizing like it's a battle
gonna battle because like when Atun you
see that cinema of the soldiers rushing
through it like it's some real game of
goals awesome differentiation this is
always amazing to like I just got to
that part that stuff goes down and I'm
like man well I remember I fought the
first boss I ain't gonna say his name at
times it could be pretty bad but I don't
care because the games list under was
for the first big boss of the game is
it's like a circle like you have to go
around in a circle to get to him I only
got two people to the
because it was so bad there's so many
people I only got like five they had
like 15 so I finally got two people to
the boss and I what to find him in on
their it lets you see the reactions it's
gonna happen at the end of that fight
and I'm like man I hit him he's gonna do
like almost he's almost killed my dude
I'm I got to like I've come too far that
thank God I got a critical and I killed
his ass of one hit but it was bad bad
like I really enjoy it feels like
tactics and it feels like the way this I
want in this this is how I feel about
about this game because I've never
played a fire yes I felt this is the
direction that tactics should have went
kind of like I feel like personas the
direction Final Fantasy should have went
like you know instead of completely
rebranding your brand to do something
different yeah to get a new audience you
you double down you make that that
formula better like I really like it
like they got a permanent fight fire in
them I'm gonna buy every fire from now
on so adding like Oh better than fail
seal oh yeah so so as much as I like the
sell out to six there you know it's
still open at interview game it doesn't
have millions of dollars being fun right
social budget well you guys should be
doing kill with the five dollars my
brother we're looking people forget the
kijima refugee camp death trend game of
the year lol you know you guys see the
video for heart man yes I'm done with
him and his strangeness I'm done this
when the game comes out I'm gonna be
wilted just like the hell I'm supposed
to do with this package he wanna climb
up a mountain and he was like we're just
gonna put a ladder up there
and we're just gonna climb with the
ladder to get up to the top of the
mountain like they put that thing where
he's dropping a ladder and it's going 90
feet across the world and I'm like hell
is this good girl I think that what I
would I would I've touched of the game I
think the game is I haven't put a whole
hell of a lot of time in the yet but
what I what I like of it is what I've
played of it so far I'm loving I think
that the game is really really good I
love the storylines of fireman games I
feel like it is the one true story
didn't end Oh does do it has a rich lore
I like also that like no two games are
alike
no to follow off each other it's can
ever I don't think that a game like this
can win game of the year yeah ultimately
because it's so neat get that this game
will probably sell a million copies but
it's not gonna be a big banger like the
other I tell you I don't know man cuz I
have I have what I do is I have
notifications from all the mom-and-pop
shops in the city right and so what yes
and when it comes when when it be games
drop I'll just get a Twitter
notification right everything GU every
last one had it about I think Wednesday
yeah they sold out of stock three times
they on and it was all fire and every
single one is about five mom-and-pop
shops every single one sold out of their
stock yeah like I went to my desk I went
I Best Buy at like 6 o'clock Friday and
they had like I said it's it's because
it's RPG because it's not even a strike
not a classic JRPG it's a strategy game
I think it turned some people off yeah
do you think what do you think now let's
ask the important question we coming up
with a you know a boy Keighley and
kijima you know it's gonna be hard to
beat that strategy and it's good
video game award but do you think it
gets nominated or than if it's put in a
separate category away from the
quote-unquote heavy hitters that end up
being finalists for gaming I can't get
nominated I think he gets nominated I do
think it's anybody here nomination but
you can get into the game cuz let's be
serious there's not been nothing this
year yeah there hasn't been anything out
there so what is it you know I mean like
it doesn't have a whole lot of games
coming you know so it's a little bit
different it's not like you've got a you
know a lot of contenders route there
where typically you have a boat like
last year and the year before there was
a mass and all yes it's a this year's
have been a little bit there's a lot of
games I'm not denying there's a lot of
games there's a lot of games not a lot
of a caliber top of the line like
everybody's talking about it
I would say there's just average games
and a little above average nothing
spectacular some that you see is like
maybe the year yes because um no I mean
let me jump in real quick King if you
don't mind because I know I didn't copy
it right there's a little logo there's a
amiibo I don't care what anybody says
that means a lot um when I go I want
full functionality of my stuff those
things are not cheap and I searched all
over the earth to get my stuff and you
know I was all waiting cues and Amazon
and stuff like that to use this stuff so
the fact that the game does have it it
guarantees my purchase of it because
when I'm sitting there and my son sees
me put my amiibo to it he understands
that he can have fun but you can be
whatever age you are I'm playing with a
toy to play a toy in a toy is his
inception at its finest I love it I
don't care what nobody I will be that
giant kid sitting on the floor
surrounded by an army of amiibos just to
get the extra fruit off the tree down to
if he walks in the door
with another amiibo his only gonna kill
him so he's got it so at least if he's
has a morality I have to have him
I got a head like I'm using them to the
side every 12 hours and breath of the
wild I countdown we were playing destiny
he's a hold I gotta be right back like
why I got it I gotta check in on our
live it look a bit quick but yo fire
when I first saw the game announced on a
direct I'm like yo it looked good
tremendous potential you know I'm saying
but initially I'm not gonna shout to the
cops come on muscle cops all right I had
no intention of buying day one saw like
I was like I'm gonna get it cuz the
backlog is crazy in Stassi that
Metacritic 99.5 someone okay
well put me over the edge we did leave
out to all my bleep of people's easy
allies they had very critical usually
when games get higher reviews and I
wanted to see what thing is gonna
nitpick at ramp and um the stuff they
were saying it was just like it's like
they look for mistake here and there but
they were saying it's so minor and it
doesn't take it away from the the
overall experience and then to be
awesome I'm an addict cuz addict is
fussy r9 addict is so damn fuzzy so if
everyone likes a he gonna present you
fuzzy bougie with his game selection so
and I know how he feels about tactics so
I get the text from attic addicts like
car this could be my game yeah from like
all you know they're so now and then the
last thing for me was I am big party yes
I come from the XCOM I come from NATO's
the dynasty Warriors to be honest you
Guru like I thought it would end up I
cannot stand dynasty Warriors game I got
scared when I saw the armies going at
each other no this is dynasty Warriors
with them and I saw the actual gameplay
mechanics in its RTS and it's it's
moving again that's what I like that
XCOM gameplay that I like and then the
thing I've really put it over the edge
to me from like a a Banner Saga is like
a tons of cinema's for everything voice
acting for everything like dad me and
the character development is what put it
over there because again Banner Saga is
like this is lit but the problem is it's
all text-based right they just reading
presbury's and again you lose that
disconnect but with these guys you got
that action you know then you've got the
voice in the cinemas you got the
character development the permadeath is
kind of fired I go front all right so
let's what we could do we could I'm just
saying with the rest of the year it's
like a spooky for the rest you know it
might be so what I'm saying is party
support we know little irrational chain
is next month yeah that's true
that could be so what about the knees
for 29 thats what i would listen i
already been anita day cuz you know
actually putting on fire straight
through right
um I gotta say this game because I'm
talking it's in the title emblem for a
baby for King if there's a question mark
yeah I'm not putting by these academies
like this come on bro he coming out on
stage believe him first you know I could
just I could just see I could just see
the speech down when I first played dead
strained you might shout it to my friend
Kojima we've been through a lot we've
been I knew I was playing a massively
would that kijima relationship I I were
each other's eyes watchin a Fire Emblem
game of the year question mark the
answer to that question is no to your
question is who will win MPD for the
rest of them Oh fine get moving and
shaking it you know again present
surprise girl use let us knows I know we
keeping you yeah you gotta bounce yeah
we gotta bust so let's let's get them
out the right way man yo salute to the
did Tendo guru
oh brother thank you so much now I know
you need a mid show but girl thank you
so much sir Mendez Jules drop
outstanding positivity love what you
doing man is honor to have you around
we'd love to have you back please tell
you any time oh thank you brother you
tell the people your channel where can
they find you what you got going on it's
simple man you can either go to the
antenna guru comm Twitter at Nintendo
gurus the YouTube channel is Nintendo
guru and you know you can find me I'm
out there I'm an idiot but seriously
seriously I didn't know about you guys -
you reached out wow I love this is the
best show I've done Wow they treat up
and that's including my stuff this you
guys are an absolute blast man it's been
an absolute pleasure
I am humbled that you even asked me
thank you so much and yeah
I can't wait any time I'm say don't do
it again
we got good stuff right yes you got you
gotta think stuff cuz I I came across
with research and stealth and I came
across one I'm like yo he's all about
bringing people in here that contacting
me switch I was only me I saw about here
fighting a good fight
just cuz he got me this week don't mean
it wasn't the zelda sticker on the mic i
got racks here in front of you with
amiibo you for you kid with some King
I'm sorry bro just because you know
forgot to open from last time here we go
I got the pokemon trainer out there in
another room I picked a pokemon trainer
got Daisy here before me there we go
there we go wow I'm gonna pull out the
fresh new joint I'll collapse over here
man come on you look I don't even know
this in a box I got these on the deck
this wide back here were you working
been let me tell you something I love to
see everyone is a king in their own
realm fact and his setup is so beautiful
the lighting the care that he takes with
his a meme of his situation his space
it's his so when I say Kos when I say
king the statues isn't that me being a
king of the statues as everybody is a
king of this situation and I swear when
I saw it I got goose bumps I love
everything about it
you went hit the lights rubber chat went
cutting they were like no everybody
loves the guru set up basic lieutenant
gruel
while your day happy born day to your
brother and I'm saying all that good
stuff have a good one we will definitely
get you back in the room more than Tendo
talk to come you already know you come
do some stuff with me
Oh honor I want to do some stuff with
you guys eat the love and all that but
you guys impressed the hell at me today
I'm floored by everything so so much
please you guys have a great rest of the
show
thank you chat likewise enjoy brother in
Telugu in the building we got some other
tablets you're gonna move on as a solve
did you all want to comment or move its
time before look I'm a real quick man
like it's it's a side story I'm telling
you they they they they did my
Wolfenstein a little bit dirty anything
they did it you know what I know you
guys would be happy they do a little bit
of Destiny in my Wolfenstein the fact
you got to play with people so don't
fall for that King I think he's trying
to trick us into buying a game okay so
that you won't buy a book so basically
let me give a little support
I know basically it's a Side Story with
a bj blaskowitz is twin daughters 20
years after the events of the new
Colossus Rhodes poorly anything about
the end of new Colossus or this cuz
there's a the time jump will tell you
some things that went down um so
basically the the premises BJ is
disappeared and his daughters go out to
try to find him and he's basically him
and Anya basically trained him to be
Nazi killers from the day they were born
so um yeah so the game is co-op now is
the first time in a Wolfenstein campaign
that you can play co-op what they have
Xbox yeah
I'm done with that experiment we gotta
buy just as they show sovereign delight
matter of fact I they on the switch us a
shop right they had like the demo up so
I'm like let me just download the demo
see how it plays right at the point of
comparison right but no it's not that
it's just that you know because this
game comes with a buddy pass if you buy
like the uh the special edition it gives
you a buddy pass and you can just give a
code to your friend if they don't own
the game they can still play the whole
game with you and co-op so that's what
that was on the eShop I'm thinking
they're giving you a little bit of a
demo of the game you can play it no
that's it's just the buddy pass so I did
not see it on switch I have not seen it
so brother
1:08 dragons TV if y'all haven't
subscribed to him subscribe to him now
please in the building I see them blue
yetis in the house love that touch stuff
what's up family and Marvel Ultimate
Alliance 3 still got no voice shout out
they did okay he's out there at he was
at QuakeCon to set up with the boys out
there playing a Youngblood you know say
but katene so wait what you think so um
again like the gameplay is very much
Wolfenstein negev okay if you played the
past Wolfenstein this new generation of
Wolfenstein it's largely the same what
they've changed though now is that
enemies have levels as as you do as well
okay so now you guys you have to level
up so you have to pay attention to the
number above that enemies head oh that's
the Destiny level area because the thing
about it is Wolfenstein has always been
about like if you face a powerful enemy
you will be there for a while trying to
kill them trying to figure out how to
kill them but it's never been about it's
never giving you clues as to what you
really need to do to beat them whereas
now with this levelling up this is a
little icon next
the enemy's telling you what they're
weak against right so now it becomes
that game of like it becomes kind of
like destiny where you got the fire to
beat this and yeah and it's right in a
Wolfenstein game that mostly should be
mostly story based I don't fit yeah it
doesn't really fit to means goal I don't
like that aspect of it I really hope
that in Wolfenstein 3 this is not part
of it this is a side story developers
you know I was saying earlier is instead
of building on the foundation that made
their franchise great they try to branch
out and make it immigrant maybe it's not
right to the game's defense I haven't
played it yet and I'm and exactly what
you're saying I know in a fast-paced
twitch game of that nature you want to
be able to keep moving and don't slow
down my question to you is does it slow
down that you have to decipher what the
shielding is and does it take away from
the pace of the game it does because the
thing about it is once once you start
grinding at certain enemies like you run
into an enemy that's too high for you
and you got to run around trying to
level up right so a in terms of the
pacing of the story they do it in such a
way that by the time you get to certain
people you're obviously gonna be at a
high enough level to beat them but it
becomes less about paying attention to
the fight then paying attention to the
numbers and paying attention to what
you're using that is causing because
they have like one level of like uh kind
of like a like armor that you have to
sort of break down before you like they
have like a like a barrier level that
you have to break down before you're
actually able to take away health from
from the enemies so it's it's that that
sort of play that sort of slows
everything down because that's not what
Wolfenstein is so again I hope they
don't do it in Wolfenstein 3 I'm not
yeah it was doing this to test the
feedback of it because it's a side story
and not their main continuum so if it's
a side story they can get away with a
little bit of play right see how the the
masses accept it or reject it so one
thing that I did like and you're right
about that I think that's what it is and
they've always done
their side stories have never been as
watched and listened to like the 15
people on Twitter and put that in three
like yeah this is great fantastic
everyone loves it I think that I did
like about what they did with this one
is that the the environments that you're
in you're in you're in Paris and you're
in three different particular sectors in
Paris um they're much wider and there
are a lot more ways to navigate it right
I think Wolfenstein has always played a
little bit kind of like a Metroidvania
where there's different ways to get to
the level and it's never been something
that's like all this black dolphins you
get an upgrade right right no never been
that but it's you've always had
different options when it came to age
when it comes to engaging people in
combat so now the the the combat areas
are much larger and they give you more
options so I that's something I do enjoy
I do hope they put in Wolfenstein 3
where it's like it gives you a lot more
options in terms of how you engage the
enemies and usually at the end of the
day even if you want to engage somebody
stealthily yeah it usually turns into a
firefight anyway at some point right
yeah very rare you're gonna be able to
stealth your way through an entire level
um so that's it like it feels like
Wolfenstein those are the things like I
was talking about with the upgrades oh
there's also weapon upgrades - oh think
about the weapon upgrades it's like they
focused on on like capacity they focused
on accuracy and then they focused on
power so there's three different like
what they call it manufacturers they
give you upgrades in each of those three
different aspects you know the thing
about it is it's like I have to see how
many weapons are in the game but
Wolfenstein has always been about the
coolness of the weapons - yeah
absolutely so when you start upgrading
different weapons just to be stronger
again that goes to the sort of the
looter shooter aspect of it where you're
upgrading maybe maybe they need some of
that destiny and that Wolfenstein to
make it pop I'm sorry not not in my
Wolfenstein so anyway so that i want to
see how many are in the game and you
know because if they're less weapons in
order to for this upgrading stuff to be
more meaningful I'm gonna
tight okay but beyond that it plays like
Wolfenstein it's fun there's there's a
lot less story beats - there's this
major story beats but there's major
story beats but they really are focusing
on the combat and the leveling up and
stuff like that so again it's in this
this stuff about it I like stuff about
it I like it
yeah the video a real quick before you
finish and I'm denim yeah I was just
gonna say like look ain't cop because
doing that Vasiliev a press a fireman
sounds good but uh not like he's eating
like I couldn't justify it because I I'm
at what is the last one was it new
Colossus was the last one again like I'm
literally at the end like I was supposed
to finish that a bitter to go and I
never got back to it like I'm really did
so I couldn't even just find out I even
beat it and then this supposed to be the
joint with his daughters but I got a
shout out Lord chance Corden y'all did
you see his tweets no he said it start
out strong but then willful style but
then you realize it's the worst parts of
Wolfenstein to copy/paste side message
missions in existing areas with boring
objectives turned into a whole game so
when I saw that Youngblood he's talking
about yeah yeah I was just like oh no
and then you talking about I'll be
honest I'm a destiny fan but I don't
know how I feel about numbers over the
dudes head like if I'm wanna sneak one
thing about what was saying I was go get
you a little sneak on your stealth on
your Merc you kill the captain do
whatever whatever you get the cold and
like if you're telling me I'm not ready
to face a certain dude I don't know how
I feel about that
yeah I'm be real like that I was
supposed to be able to do what I want
get my I want to kill everything thing
always takes like every time someone
says you need to be this tall come in
this ride I'm like no I don't yeah over
the fence to the left and still kill
that dude like will alluded when Louie
shooter okay
but what this has never been that so I
don't understand why did need for that
yeah
they just trying out new things I mean
we get all the developers for nothing so
true and continuing to do the same old
thing but I think there is some pressure
to make the game replayable and playable
like who doesn't want somebody to
continue to play the game
shout out to breakfast with bull shout
out to war I was on his show and on
Friday in the morning and we talked
about the reason why they weren't
showing the campaign who is a war five
and the narrative is in eSports and
continuing playing these games yeah
that's that's gonna generate revenue
that's gonna much forward so you want to
build up as much replay value in your
game as possible
we are dinosaurs now that campaign stuff
you know we can do it but once we finish
it like cognizant I want to finish it so
I could put it to the side right never
go back to it again
mmm so if they can build some aspect
into the game that can allow you to keep
coming back I think that's a good thing
because don't we want ultimately want
ultimate value from our games and our
memories yeah you're right in that
regard the problem is that we Youngblood
it feels like a shoehorned in run it
feels like it's something that not that
they added last minute I'm sure they
plan for this from the beginning but
it's something that they haven't done
before and then they're adding it again
adding it to a franchise that has
traditionally not had it so you're gonna
get pushback on that as it is right so
and in people just like you said it's a
side story I think that's why people
letting it slide and it's getting the
reviews it's getting but it's not
getting the outrage that it's getting
because I can tell you this if
Wolfenstein 3d ops and it's this but you
notice they are fillet didn't really
market disjoint not even lobby map it
was like your way it's coming out this
week how come I hear enough in a body
like but doesn't be kind of you know put
the market into this one man but no yeah
I just want to addicts gotta go soon so
I want to kind of get him speed along
with his joy if you don't mind you don't
say it like a dick bro so we gonna talk
about some crunch man
Oh naughty dog so for sure a lot of you
remember the outrage that Rockstar got
for crunching their employees I don't
even remember how it was like 15 hour
days or something like that Rockstar did
yes I'm like that whoa let me tell you
what looks like Rockstar over there on
the border of just having slavery going
on home they're clear they're supposedly
running people 24-hour days sometimes do
not display to depict somebody's work
conditions so so apparently you know
it's it's rumored that they've been
working certain days and certain people
it's been working 24-hour shifts mmm
like yeah obviously you have a lot of
people first off I don't think that
something like that is even feasible if
someone's working 24-hour shifts that's
critical management needs to be fine
well good are they to you at that point
like what good bone baby to the boat my
family can face captain I want to attack
this face first because we talked about
this on Brooklyn so boom again yes let's
get it all right um I have no sympathy
for your brother right now because at no
point time did they say they were not
getting paid mmm now again mm-hmm I
cannot cry for you for you having a job
I can't you see you picking that job I
cannot cry for you see you working that
job I cannot cry for you if you're
getting paid now maybe some people say
they're not getting paid a fair wage
mm-hmm so at no point in time because
I'm pretty sure to CEO new flowers
shifts mm-hmm all right so it's balling
down to the level of education
to you accepting this job therefore
complaining afterwards because you're
working 24 hours the game is going to
get out
maybe conclude and if you work a little
bit that's one thing but we talking 24
hours what would you do it what do you
mean what I was in that situation yeah
to you and told you today you're working
til tomorrow there's a couple stairs you
can go you can a quit what someone in an
established career that's been working
in that industry for 15 years that's not
an option
hmm cuz if you quit you're not going
anywhere else because you've been you
quit lighten the in this industry small
you only probably do it is only probably
got like good well paint these you might
have a couple hundred job description
that you could possibly apply for and
we're not even talking about if you want
to just up and move your family to
another state another country yeah it's
like look like we need to stop blaming
the people they're doing it start
blaming the managers that are poorly
doing time to math to do 124 our grunts
time in the past I would have a guy I
think I I've agreed with King on this
way it's like I don't I'm not crying for
you when this is what you picked it
where I would agree with that but since
then they've been a few different expose
days coming out about the new is about
this stuff and what bothers me is like
what King secular King you said improve
your education right yeah a lot of times
these guys right out of college and have
a lot of education that office Lee don't
have the experience right so they go
into these companies as contractors know
and they have they have the expertise
right they don't have the experience and
I'm glad for that I'm on the job and
it's something if you if you somebody
whose dream has been to work in gay max
you gotta bend over backwards sustain ik
the via kinky like I'm wonder just say
like it's one thing to come and be like
look like we got a crunch time like we
got to get this part of this game done
by next week so they can start their
part
and you know people come together they
do them than 16 and 24 hours for maybe
maybe a day or a day a week or that one
time and then they move on but this is
happening over and over again it's we
gotta get Billy we gotta get for the
evening yeah no doubt this is why I said
this a child a brother Philly Eagle with
the ten dollar super cheque to Kings
Point many of those devs are in no
competition contracts they can't seek
employment elsewhere while still working
because of that many are locked in
because they can't afford to be without
work right now Philly this is what I'm
talking about now this is what I want
intelligent chat conversation and what
you're saying is true you want to tell
it you chat conversation at the dollar
when I worked for a glass company on
auto glass company I sign a non-compete
clause now I could not open up a glass
business within three years of not
working there I could not work for
another glass company because I had
trade secrets and knowledge behind the
background and I was an independent
contractor and no point in time was I
paid exactly what I felt that was worth
point in time that I feel because I
understand what you're saying
once they quit they are locked out you
can't work for somebody else what are
you gonna do work at a fast-food
restaurant with this level of education
like Solomon said yeah they have the
education but they got a grimy teeth to
get in there and it's a bad machine
that's taking people and grinding them
to dust making a power and and pushing
them to the side now maybe the strong
survive and push on and get to the next
game and and hopeful and hope for better
work conditions mmm problem is that the
strong survive under those conditions
and they become acclimated to operating
those conditions survive and say no once
we get to the top we're gonna change
this they just continue date they just
do it to the next book cycle yes
the mega-hit ship with zero 3000 kids
out of college don't understand the
house they work they stroll in at any
time which Starbucks speaking asleep get
your butt to work yes I mean it's just
that thing like you do have to be taught
a certain work ethic obviously the game
industry has always been this way the
problem is that to me
you're killing off half of the people
that could be in it could be future you
know top devs by introducing them to
this to this cycle from the very
beginning that doesn't appreciate what
they are putting into it and then
another thing about it gets me about
gaming wrong again I don't know anything
about game development but right these
big games Percy Triple A games talk
about Naughty Dog games take five six
seven years to make or it's baffling to
me I guess I don't know the process but
it's baffling to me that you have to
crunch to finish a game with that much
time giving to make the game like
whatever crunch today for hours for a
game is taken you seven eight years to
make mm-hmm it's crazy to me what do you
guys say you know to the kind of point
that you know these guys know what they
signed up for you know and that comes
with the territory and there should be
no complaining because it's deflecting
from the fact that the territory is
messed up my official stance on the fact
is one you're never gonna hear me
complain about work that I chose to do
right but again at the same time and I
gave you my scenario where I was in a
situation with that exact thing were
perpetrated upon myself now in saying
this you always have control mm-hmm
right now maybe you may not like the
result of your answer for what you're
about to do next and no point in time
are you out of control you're always in
control and remember there's a cause and
effect for everything
mm-hmm right and I don't think that it's
fair life is not about being fair mm-hmm
okay so now that they're learning this
and what Simon Says is
when you are in a position mm-hmm change
it because they're not gonna be
unionized that's not gonna happen
all right because they get a finite
amount of money and they only hire
independent contractors to work with a
non-compete clause that locks them in
that's how they grab you by the gonads
and want you to do their bidding basic
right right but let me let me let me
bring something in today didn't anything
and I know soft mention contractor shout
out the breath I was on prep you had a
rant this Saturday we kind of touched
this real briefly I I guess for me I
understand what you guys are saying but
the contractor things a little
differently because I'm the way I look
at it solve you kind of alluded to this
which is like what I used to do contract
working on tea right the thought process
is look look I got the you know you just
got your degree or whatever it is you
just got now you're trying to get in the
game and they like yo you got you know
the piece of paper but you ain't got the
experience ooh we ain't hiring right so
you go through this process of trying to
find trying to get on and everybody's
like yeah you qualify by getting I know
experience like yo how do I get
experience right so then you know this
way the contracting comes in where it's
like look we ain't giving you no
Bennie's but you're gonna work at
company a is a big reputable company
gonna be doing this you're gonna grind
out for whatever whatever so the thought
process for a lot of contractors is that
look I'm doing this to try to get on
right and my doing this and I impressed
them then maybe I get aid a hope of a
full-time position with this company
that I really want to with this industry
that's my quote so quote unquote dream
or experience and get experience so
that's why a lot of people kind of
subject themselves to things then you
know I'm saying cuz the whole thing is
no one else is giving me a shot then
you've got the aspect of okay I hear
your point thing about controlling you
are right everyone has the right say you
know what you're saying it you know and
I get that part but again two addicts
point which is like yo if I storm out
mm-hm you're fired or whatever because
the industry is so small and everyone
knows everyone whatever done there's a
strong chance that they'll be like yo
cog he left during last of us is crunch
let me when you got a B let me call your
past employer
to do that guy we're trying to give Joel
he left during infancy he's what he's
the reason job didn't have a beer don't
hire you don't say he's the remember one
mass effect we had to bed in and that's
the guy we wanted him to put in the town
for the ending sequence he had but Ruth
and that kind of a stigma you know
saying because it's so small again it's
it's a tough one man because I get what
you're saying and guess the normal
industries I guess when you have more
options more opportunities i'm which i
love they doing it dirty but for some
people this they dream it's only one do
you know people do what i've seen more
of being a chance to go to pax mmm-hmm
some people take their destiny into
their own hands and they make own games
I've seen too many teams make a game oh
now we're gonna show examples of that
now I seen a brother team get together
wouldn't husband-and-wife team without a
2-ton
a lot of times these conditions force
these conditions force somebody with
their drive and that ability just to
push forward and to change their
circumstance in such a dramatic way
and I'm not saying that it's right I'm
not saying that it's fair because I
think out there what I am saying is this
you have choice don't give up your
choice mmm fresh out that what a weight
he would be Mark Jackson a black ball
last question real quick before one last
time with a lot for that is that on in
reference to I went to a shot it's do
you think like with this whole crunch
culture thing that's coming out
obviously getting a lot of expose
skittish rise and all these world you
know do this do you think because of
Naughty Dog's or certain companies
cachet right like there's certain
companies that they all belong because
of classic franchise is whether it be
Last of Us whether it be on chart or
whatever it may be right do you feel
like like some some companies aren't
like
a bit more shielded because the quality
of the studio is so good there people
like yo regardless to what I'm Brian lol
you know they like you know Miyamoto be
slave I believe that certain caches
companies some of some of these elite
companies use that and they don't but
doesn't that look good on your resume
that you worked on oh absolutely
doesn't look great on your resume so
this double-edged sword do you want that
on your resume but how bad are you
willing to work for it four hours a day
may sound crazy that might have been one
date like buddy this guy's not coming in
I need you to work his shift
while you do it I mean you're a two-hour
break period you can go crash out over
here real quick we can give you that
lunch piece but we need you right back
into the fold King for all we know they
they could be getting like five six
hours of sleep between crunches to so I
mean I know I did so he has a room that
you could sleep if you get if you get
mandated and sometimes you'll get stuck
at dish and you'll have my date got
listening listen to the joystick people
are saying and there's sometimes you
know I'm saying they were really
provided with dinner
or oats for the OT crunch you know a lot
of them are saying that they were barely
paid above minimum wage somewhat I'm 60
to 80 hours work sweet Dee's somebody's
report again you know these are off the
record and in fairness and I'm saying
he's literally treated like stepchildren
and the one thing I were they had like a
yoga session like the did the devs and
they explicitly said the contractors are
not allowed there's not I don't people
you have to understand something right
when you are independent contractor you
are not
the the blanket or the umbrella of the
right you don't have medical you don't
have a lot of things that are going with
the fact of being a full-time employee
and a lot of these guys that's in this
crunch want to be that full-time
employee right a lot of these guys want
to impress you to become that full-time
employee are they taking advantage of
you yes now I can give you a for
instance Brian remember that time when I
was working in sanitation at home in
Albert Einstein and um they moved me up
to the animal Institute right and they
put me on a padeen situation with me and
another guy and we had to impress these
guys to get the job well what happened
is at the end of that function even
though I was a lead guy the other guy
got um picked mm-hmm right so I went
right back down the housekeeping and
then two weeks later they said they were
impressed with me they didn't realize
that I was actually the one I was doing
everything and it moved me up to animal
Institute at that period of time we were
we were doing some ungodly stuff like
they were sending us inside room to
sanitize and clean scrub sealing stuff
that wasn't in the job description and I
wasn't I wasn't um what's imma call it
on salary or with the company I was you
know independent contractor basically
but I worked hard and I got the job I'm
not telling you and anybody else that is
under crunch that is under poor working
dishes to tough it out I'm telling you
to do the best that you can with what
you got if you cannot do it let me tell
you something mental breakdowns and and
stuff that we talked about earlier but
because people don't know their own
limits mmm know your limit if somebody's
pushing you to that limit mm-hmm no I
mean chief made a good point though what
about you know the whole concept of
Stockholm Syndrome people getting beaten
today minded this is the norm that's the
thing is because the thing is if you if
you come into the industry as a contract
and you say okay I have to do X Y Z to
be able to get ahead and people to see
me and to hopefully get a full time
right you do all that you Sparkle you
work 24 hours shifts you come in you get
a great job and then you it's still the
same if you have a great paying job
you're in the in-crowd now you're in the
boys club now and the culture is still
the same mmm and rather than say hey I
suffered through this rather than say I
suffered through this and it wasn't
right let me see what I can do to change
it now that I'm in a position to be able
to do that people's thinking is well if
I did it that's what I did you have to
do the same thing and that sort of stuff
it's just a snowball effect of you just
keep teaching the bad teachings you know
and that's the thing and one thing we
haven't touched on this very real is
that a lot of these dev studios I mean
they have bosses they have to speak to
they have publishers that are really the
ones that really sort of you know with
certain deadlines we're certain this has
to be out in quarter one quarter two
whatever the case may be when it comes
to money once the money situation
dictates how and when the game has to
come out then forget about it then even
the thought of within the studio trying
to fix this problem that goes out the
window as well because now you have now
you have you know investors to think
about you have that influences the game
but let me ask you this stuff if you
really hitting some things I know we
gotta move on but what do you think with
all this investigative stuff and this
stuff coming out and people you know
saying things off record what do you
think this will actually give the drive
to eventually unionize the gaming
industry well I think in the long term I
think it'll start it was not definitely
moving the wheels I forgot what shows
their gigs a gig because I'm thinking
about I think it was um me point I I
might be wrong about this I think it was
way point though maybe even kind of
funny where they had a guy on who's
who's worked in the game industry for
quite some time
I forgot what Debbie works for but he's
actively like one of the head people
that's sort of unionized trying to
unionize people across the games
industry so it's like a big movement
with a with a few people at the hell
of this trying to get people on the same
page in terms of unionization I don't
know if they're talking about
unionization across the board or maybe
lower-level employees but the
conversation is happening and it's calm
and it's happening well the problem with
it with the game industry is right that
it's all over the place right it's not
centralized and it was very difficult to
get people on board and like Philly
Eagle said like they can only utilize if
the employee agrees to the terms exactly
but but you need that pressure and the
only way you're gonna get pressure is
with numbers and the problem has been
getting the numbers because of how how
separated everyone is so I this dude I
forget his name but he he was he was his
focus is trying to go from place to
place trying to get as many people on
board so that you actually have numbers
behind what they're talking about
once you got the numbers and you have
people on the same page then you can
start moving the needle real quick
thanks for contacting Microsoft support
for Xbox I'm following up on your refund
request at your request to order placed
on July 25th 2019 has been refunded
thank you Microsoft not choose that
definitely need to check your
subscription to make sure it's upgraded
and cancelled we got to move all four
Lord tablets it's King segue so
perfectly into his subject big Lord
filled ominous you know saying well I
gotta explain something to you right now
I want you to set it up real quick and
then I gotta explain something that
happened recently okay the light of this
whole interview yeah so pretty much
filled ominous with alone he knows it's
now say impromptu but I didn't hear
about it and it surprised us on fortune
magazine right and I mean yeah Phil
Spencer watch a magazine and he dropped
some gems he was about of forty to fifty
minute interview talking about Xbox
profitability a whole bunch of subjects
so
I sent the information out to lords and
king took advisor brains the Lord King
man what did you feel about Phil Dom its
xbox only begotten sons recent fortune
interview ok so we all know when we came
back from e3 I said Phil became Phil
political and you know on reflecting on
everything and I watched the I watched
the show a couple of times over
hey listen to various opinions and I got
I took my emotions out of it ok all
right and I said ok no he's still filled
ominous oh this situation is exactly
what it is and he did what's best now
what I liked about this interview that
is up on Fortune magazine you can go to
the website you can check it out they
had a hostile interviewer into like the
level of questioning already showed you
what was he leaning to you what was
going on what type of clickbait stuff he
was doing and in light of this new
interview I want to say that in the
Roman days when Caesar or Marcus
Aurelius they conquered another land
they got another title to their name so
fill Dominus
there's no longer filled Dominus his
name is Phil Dominus Maximus that he and
a versatility that he displayed in this
interview oh he broke down as to why he
told you unapologetically no we were bad
and we will do better he sat in front of
you answered the hard questions that not
one company ahead of a division
will do because I don't think you're
gonna have a Bowser taking these
questions mmm
what the softball question Aloha
question special ability he went at Phil
without blinking Dominus Maximus
[Music]
deflected it broke it down and showed
you why in this industry he said you
guys acting like we're at each other's
throats we are friends hmm I
congratulate it Phil what he worked it
but let me tell you something about the
reason why Xbox only begotten Son it's
who he is
he told you mm-hmm these dudes at the
competition that dudes the competition
mmm these dudes we put games out on a
platform you tell mama refers to the
micro minecraft shots OD like we do that
I'll peep that and let me tell you how
he minimized Stadium mm-hmm he did it
Phil used to work here
oh you say he's got the shot he said
that was my son
Phil how he minimized it is this even
well even more than that because he'd be
shot out if he said Phil and I are great
friends we talked before the stadium
launch but it wasn't a diss track but
what he how he meant in my stadia was
this mm-hmm says stadia is trying to get
you it's trying to tell you leave that
place where you play no I'm here to play
mm-hmm that's not what we're telling you
we're telling you keep playing there we
love you playing it mm-hmm
you can play here as well I'll paved
this for us so right there he's he's
saying we're giving you an option in
addition to what you have already right
I'm gonna get you to change your entire
way of playing right and at first he'd
insinuated like it's just different and
then he threw that in he compared it to
what they're doing and at that point it
wasn't different anymore
he knows it's obvious that ours is
better
because you can't once you're telling me
okay exclude something to play here or
just add to what you already have and
you have more options to play here
nobody in their right minds gonna be
like I'm gonna go with the exclusionary
thing I'm not mmm
it's so tactfully I think when it comes
to to to to Barry sander in your way
around interviews and stuff like him and
red eyes do button was on flea him and
Reggie Reggie is very good at doing the
same thing around stuff and I think that
to me yeah he has been xed oh yeah and
decided to you know to to walk away like
you know shout-out to Chris for being
petty he's like Lord Phil fraud abyss
back service I did peep that joy sob
where he he you know he talked about you
know the stadia giant you know I'm
saying and highlight you know how their
approach is different I mean these are
things I got these are the keys I got
for me he talked about the X cloud
trying love what he said in reference to
them looking at all the developers
locations around the world right and
placing the X cloud data centers closer
to them so they can actually test that
out through the API all that that's fine
that's forward thinking getting people
to see that stuff and you know again
it's building API should be easy
transition I like that um he talked
about the competition you know I'm
saying and how like King is saying like
yo he strike that they don't look at
that as a competition thing cuz these
guys are friends you know I'm saying he
looked at the friends lationship and he
the key point he said to me was just
like I don't need an opposing studio to
fail so it could be like Team Green
don't think could win that was that was
style some boss talk I respect the way
we that with that the Xbox from Billy
was a little shaky cuz no pressing him
did you hear mmm-hmm and say then now
the support that he has right helps him
move
he said before financially they warrant
being checked on right
he said now ten billion dollars it's
still money is not Microsoft company
money but now they're talking about us
in conversation that we generate revenue
and to to to to be that transparent to
tell you before that we weren't even
being heard I was surprised over them
when he pressed him with that is my xbox
profitable he didn't come right back
with well look at our services all right
our services on all these platforms come
out he didn't come back with that which
is weird to me I don't think that would
have been that the the moment to say
that it bring up like Schmucks game path
watch your magazine they you know they
don't have money talk so he wanted they
do wanted to know interviewer wanted to
know yo at what year did it because he
caught it was dancing I'm not gonna it's
not that it's not making money I'm just
saying that he was pressed on that and
it was a little shaky that part he's
just saying I look at the numbers and I
you know it's definitely profitable most
every possible that kind of thing so you
know some people don't look at that like
your fam right got the numbers on that
you know saying look at it as fam
where's your CEO up here today same
slinging arrows no no no you don't say
and then the other thing was about the
arm you know the game's not married to
the device you know we heard that
already and I'm saying as far as that he
wants it to be multiple places that's
the key you know the stadia dish track
was lit i don't front the bars he do a
stadia he's like we are not locking you
trying to move you off a console he's
saying go play here X cloud as a choice
you know I mean look at the end of the
day the giant you know he admit it like
Kings say you know that issues they have
at this point look in this I'm gonna
defend him only because these are
questions he's asked right so he's gonna
shoot a shy gonna say what he understood
I'm just at the point y'all like not
that he shouldn't do interviews anymore
it's just like I just want to see the
game I am tired of waiting right I am
tired of yo it's gonna be late on this
or do you know a couple years watch
what's gonna do by
that's cool I know your work I know
right now the long game what it is but
until the long game gets here which is
the launch of the Scarlet all that I
really don't want to hear about how ill
is gonna be like just Shh and just and
then when you got the beggars everybody
gotta been Denis right that's all I'm
saying that's all that's why I would you
not that though I watched interview I
was highly upset I was completely
agitated at the line of questioning then
I felt that Phil dominus Maximus but in
watching it you know certain times the
reason why you mess with certain people
when he said the head is aligned with
the body and they're looking forward and
it wasn't like that that's because the
interviewer even tried to press him on
the past regime yeah a peep that and he
said and I'm gonna tell you right now
oh boy had bullet points he had all the
bullet points that is on the Internet
that is on Twitter that's on Facebook
this in every chat that's ever been
talked about on reddit or anywhere else
he had every last sling of arrows and he
shot his shot completely at Phil did
Phil walk away unscathed no but what it
also does is he sits there answers the
hard questions becomes accountable and
tells you I can't do anything about the
past but what's going forward and what's
gonna happen forward is you can hold me
accountable to these words right in heat
show III really have real faith in that
because I don't see nobody else it meant
doing that in it okay so basically what
you say it is like yo at the end of the
day like you know ain't no other
executive being put through this and
he's willing to throw himself out in the
fire as opposed to
and it didn't feel like it was so
pre-canned like again cuz there were
moments where he got kind of stuck a
little yeah and I was like okay cuz for
me what suck out most was when he the
interviewer kind of brought out their
like the fanboy stuff and about how it
you know Phil deflected it saying like I
don't want to see anybody fail what good
does it do me like and that's kind of
that's kind of our view here when we
talk about the fanboys and stuff like we
joke or whatever we have our preferences
but at the end of the day I would never
want Nintendo to fail I never want any
one of these companies to fail because
in turn your product all of a sudden
becomes worse by by having one less
competitor in fact so the fact that he
he kind of people the way he attacked
them was he's like okay you're giving me
all this kumbaya stuff now right
everybody you want everybody to do well
understand the other at the same time
your marketing doesn't always say that
your marketing is your marketing and and
you know we've seen it you know
obviously we got some behind the scenes
stuff from e3 with fan fest some words
that were said behind the scenes they
were a little bit you know attacking
certain people that weren't there
you know and it's and it goes back to
something we're talking about earlier in
today's podcast about marketing from
back in the day Genesis does what
nintendon't and I know crash bandicoot
rolling up on Nintendo and you know so
it's and they still do it today not as
directly as the ads back in the day but
when they can take jabs at each other
they do it and so he questioned me said
well okay so if you're telling me that
you guys are all together but at the
same time you still have people who
gravitate towards this other type of
marketing then that postulates you as
want better than the other than the
other platform or whatever
what do you how is it that you can't you
you have to pay attention to those
people because if you look at where Xbox
one is this generation it's largely in
the position it is now or it is largely
taken so long to get to where it is now
because of what happened at the start of
the generator
that's max and that all came from you
know initial reactions to things you did
negatively so it's like how do you each
I send Phil tried to say you know I to
listen too much to social media like I
hear stuff but the stuff that's most
important bubbles up to the top and then
everything else sort of is is noise
right and it's just you know fanboy BS
going back and forth but I like the fact
that he questioned them on that because
these companies it they kind of get kind
of hypocritical in that regard
right like working together you know and
we're all going towards a goal and I
think actually that is what's happening
but at the same time you do have to
market you want your product to sell
right you don't want to be oh don't get
my product my product sucks
oh but again I like the fact that he did
he brought that up because if it forces
you to have to answer that question hmm
for all to see like what how do you
really deal with this because you have
two phases as a company you do have two
phases it's just the facts very
interesting interview I definitely liked
what I saw and um there was some key
points in a like King City he dealt with
the hostility so yeah that's all I got
is get on it we're definitely running
late we gotta get out of here
but um yeah Matt's get this ILP poll
popping with a critically acclaimed
release of Fire Emblem three houses it's
sweet and it's not where lineup for the
rest of the year do you think this will
translate to Nintendo winning NPD
hardware sales but the remainder of 2019
oh stop being gassed cog xbox will at
least win one month be switch train full
steam ahead covered it hot undefeated
for remaining of 2019 or see I don't
care
switch joy Conn drift and terrible
online service always keeps them in the
bushes
that is the question those are the
choices like that I'll be vote when it
goes up to morrow Lord Nintendo guru was
an absolute pleasure in the hell we got
to get that brother back
oh we're not stories Oh tremendous match
of many beacon of positivity out here in
the community doing what he do we will
definitely have it poppin so yeah let's
get up idea Attica you know we had to
get to work but Lord solve wicked if I'm
gonna find you but do you have going on
sir hopefully playing a little more
Wolfenstein and definitely fire helm to
the rest of the week you know hopefully
my eye gets better but I think I can put
on my other contact lens by Thursday
both eyes back oh that's so know that
Lord King bringing the heat as always
wicked if I people find what you got
going on sir all right well this week we
got a new statue going up for those that
didn't get a chance to see the
saber-tooth that's up behind you
thinking of the Lords of gaming that net
we might actually check out the whole
dimensions of the statue you can get a
little synopsis about him and then you
can go watch the video where I can give
you an in-depth because a lot of you
confused this character with a
Wolverines nemesis and I'm here to sadly
break that news to you he's not also I
was going to do a combat talk with the
King yesterday because you had a
terrible former fighting his mandatory
and you also had Javonte tank davis
fighting his mandatory both fights was
you know basically a wash the only fight
where it was an upset it was a hunter
got upset maurice hunter but he's hooker
got upset and i knew who's gonna get
upset anyway because he wasn't ready for
that level competition at this point in
time it's korea so um none of those
fights was worthy of your time but this
cyborg with this put on a master class
in MMA yesterday if you did not see it
please go up and check it out oh I do
I've always been in love with her
fighting style I always thought that she
was you know little woman to be feared
but knew
showed me otherwise yeah it was it was
it was a great night of fights shot the
max Halloween night all the way Felicia
Spencer tuvo hey Cris cyborg and shout
out to the to the old future Hall of
Famer Frankie Edgar Frankie
I mean look he availed himself well but
I mean Max is just too big for him like
what about big country though in that
Bellator oh the Senior Circuit I don't
know about the Foxwoods League Fox so
who did he stretch out doing it up over
there no doubt no doubt you already know
got that king of statues up why like I
say number 18 up on loads of gaming
dinette check that out the last word
would eat boxes went up on Friday with
the Red Queen and absolutely fantastic
positive guest one of our best ever on
the last word she should trend this love
you please check that out is up or ILP
you already know roundtable reviews is
up there still we're gonna be doing more
we got more cooking and make that ice
that out make it a little better we're
gonna show you our song you're not I'm
saying and Dom yeah man that's all I got
in reference to that everybody enjoy
your Sunday we will catch our next week
and we out peace